[Music]
[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody it's us it's wednesday
night hey you're wearing one of the new
canon shirts yeah we've got the new
canon shirt
that's gonna be for sale
yeah they're gonna be for sale i mean
i'm probably gonna have to order some
blank shirts and i had to order some
more ink although the ink should be here
tomorrow because i made sure that i got
it like next day shipping and uh i think
murder harness is in there any
i don't know i haven't seen him yet okay
all right
because i got the uh the ocp shirt done
or i got the ocp screen done
yeah he didn't scream last night yeah i
just haven't sh i haven't shot one out
yet i don't have the uh the
the die yeah well we'll get the die
tomorrow yeah we should have we'll i'll
talk about them i'll pump them later on
yeah and i when there's more people here
yeah so uh hopefully everybody's having
a good day today i think this is gonna
be
a fun show even though well i mean it
does kind of start out with a horrible
disaster so that's not so fun but
this was actually kind of like an
interesting topic that i think i
mentioned this before but
i'd heard of the disaster that this was
predicated on um because i've been there
but um i didn't i had never heard of the
british premonitions bureau
prior to seeing it on uh that show the
unexplained with william shatner which i
think was from 2019
right because we were watching it on
hulu yeah we still got a lot of those to
watch we do yeah um
so yeah and i i seem to see it on one
was where they were talking about i
guess they were just talking about psych
except for esp or precognition or
something it's a good series you guys
need to see it it's got the chat it's
kind of like doing in search of
like a modern modern day version of
instagram yeah they're pretty good yeah
they do like themes and they just i mean
a lot of the stuff that you know we've
covered on the show
but it's just like a quality but like i
said every now and then they come up
with something like this that i actually
hadn't heard of before
and sometimes the date is new
yeah because it's a newer show yeah it's
newer shows they've updated some of the
cases you know you've heard the case
before but then there's like a little
bit of an update in this [ __ ] to happen
so it's good good this one it's
interesting because i was looking for
some other um kind of youtube videos to
see how much this uh this idea this case
had like penetrated the you know
youtube-a-spear i guess
um i found one like podcast about it
where it was kind of like our show where
it was two guys and they were just kind
of like [ __ ] around half the time um
but then like talking about the actual
case the other half of the time but i
think it was only an hour long and then
it was kind of like a short thing now
the um
a book has come out about it a guy named
sam knight
wrote a book about this like an in-depth
thing and he also did a really in-depth
write-up about the book and about the
case for the new yorker which is where i
got a lot of the information for this
show um i was going to read the book too
but the e-book was a little bit
expensive and i was just kind of like
well i don't know if i have time to like
read it before the show but he did such
a good write-up for the new yorker that
i was like well that will probably be uh
you know too good and i'll just get like
some other stuff but i kind of feel like
i don't know this is something that sort
of like slips under the radar i guess
like i feel like some of the big
paranormal shows and stuff haven't
really covered it british government
trying to keep track well it wasn't the
government actually no not really not
really it was just well i mean it was
very short-lived okay and it was kind of
like it was just an idea
and it was almost it was kind of like a
psychiatrist and like a journalist and
like a newspaper they were kind of like
working together and they said if this
works out right um then we'll go to
parliament and we'll see if we can get
funding for it stuff like that but
you know well yeah and it didn't work
out for like for some reason but it's
nice this is it's really interesting
because
i mean if premonitions are real i don't
know like there are like some really
creepy uh you know people saying that
they saw us have a head but
the thing about it and something i kind
of want to get into when we talk about
this show is that and i think it's a
problem that they ran into as well
was that you know even if you have like
a [ __ ] ton of
people having a premonition about
something it's like how do you
necessarily go about preventing it or
what if the premonitions are kind of
like too vague to know like you know oh
all these people for example like had a
premonition of like a plane crash but
it's like you know millions of planes
are flying around how do you know like
which one it is so i can see like the
idea behind it but in practice it might
not really be that i mean it might be
more viable nowadays i feel like because
i mean they did this we're doing this
back in the 60s when you didn't really
have computers or anything i kind of
feel like maybe now
um if you had something like this at
least you could have like some ai that
would give you like some patterns and
peaks and things like that i think they
already have something kind of like that
i don't think it has to do with
premonitions but you know like the
things were like there's a lot of
chatter about this that and the other
and that's kind of how they predict like
certain things will happen i think which
is kind of like the same thing yeah i
remember hearing something about that
like almost 10 15 years ago that they
were using
a super computer taking headlines and
this and that and data and trying to
predict the future with it
i doubt it's possible
yeah the thing about it it's like you
could probably get some [ __ ] right but
trends maybe you could get yeah anything
that was like trend-based or if it was
like really likely to happen or
something like that like i can see you
getting that but
the thing about it is like like i said
we've talked about this a lot it's like
reality is very messy it's very
complicated there's just too many
factors that you can't account for even
if you have a super computer that's
working on it you know there's always
like one little thing that like throws
everything like butterfly effect that
throws everything off into like a
completely totally different direction
that nobody expected if you're using
newspaper
accounts and news reports that's really
going to [ __ ] it up because a lot of
things a lot of a lot of the news is
very selectively reported
and then headlines are kind of already
biased in a certain way so if you're
adding that into into a computer
it'd be like the damn
that
jallow title um
generator that that program that'll just
generate it down that yellow movie
shallow movie title i'll sit there all
day and do that that is like so
entertaining to me because if you're
putting garbage in the into the program
you're going to get garbage out of it i
mean that's just that's speaking of the
of the giallo name generator i actually
designed a game like a card game where
you essentially do that it's just like a
[ __ ] ton of cards with like different
giallo esque words on it and you get it
and you and you have to come up with
a really cool sounding title and then
you have to come up with like a pitch
for like the movie that that is that
that is describing something like that
would only but yeah i made a game like
that it would only work if you had a
super computer that was sentient that
would know
how unreliable data is and to know when
somebody's lying and to really know the
outside world and then maybe it would be
able to give you a basic trend of what
could happen
it would know about statistics you know
when will the next big meteor hit
statistically they would go oh well
statistically we got 10 000 years before
the next big meteor hit it'd be [ __ ]
like that
i mean i kind of feel like they already
have stuff like that i mean stuff like
that that doesn't really have anything
to do with human action right you know
what i mean especially the stuff that's
like astronomical because like we can't
really do [ __ ] about that um you know
weather patterns we can't really affect
that to any great degree so i kind of
feel like things that are statistically
based like that probably work a lot
better things that are have to do with
human behavior or human actions i don't
think you're gonna like how you're kind
of gonna know about that if you had a
sentient super computer and you started
asking any questions about the future of
mankind it would probably just give
responses kind of like a snotty human
would it would just say well you you're
humans and y'all are [ __ ] up and
you're dumb you know you probably be
around for another thousand years and it
would just be regenerate generalities
you know
if we genetically engineer you'd be
better you might live be around longer
you know
it but you would just tell you things
like that i don't think it would be
anything you could set your clock to
john smith said i met william shatner
once in a hotel if you wanted to talk to
you don't bring up star trek bring up tj
hooker he'll talk all day about that
yeah yeah
well he's probably like sick of it i
imagine yeah he didn't he's sick of damn
star trek uh conventions and [ __ ]
yeah he was sick of that [ __ ] back in
the 80s well yeah i imagine i mean i can
see that though be i mean the thing
about it is that star trek is so beloved
and but it's really like i said it's
like a double-edged sword because it's
like yeah it's really cool like that you
were part of something so beloved but
then after a while you're like you know
i did other [ __ ] too can we please talk
about something else the shad's lived a
good life
okay he's been shielded from a lot of
the [ __ ] up [ __ ] i really liked him in
that christmas anthology where he was
like in the frame story like the dj yeah
he was
a lot of fun in that he got drunker and
drunk over the course of the movie they
sent his ass to space yeah
just his ass just just his ass it
weighed a lot
john smith said i just checked out the
giallo generator my title is one streak
of crimson on the cold metal table
well i did i i designed another game
that was like a a giallo style murder
mystery and i called it a crimson drop
on a crystal palette because it's set in
a museum like it's all around museums
and like pieces of art and stuff
that's what an ai computer would tell
you about man's future it would just be
it would probably be [ __ ] like that
probably yeah but you know i don't know
i kind of feel like and another thing
too that i really wanted to get into
because i found this probably the most
fascinating [ __ ] about this whole
british premonitions bureau and one of
the things that the psychiatrist that
started it was really interested in too
was
is it possible if you actually like
believe that you're gonna die like in a
specific way or at a specific time like
does it actually make you die is it like
a self-fulfilling prophecy um he was
like actually really interested in that
and there was a little bit of that going
on uh you know in the british
premonitions bureau situation as well so
i kind of want to get into that too
because i thought that was like really
interesting like all the kind of stuff
about placebo effect nocebo effect all
that kind of stuff i find that stuff
really fascinating as did he so you know
uh slasher fred said if you guys ever
see the movie galaxy quest that movie
was a spoof of star trek yeah that movie
is actually really really good um you
would probably love that if you haven't
seen it have you seen galaxy quest that
was the comedy right yeah this must be
good like yeah it is it's yeah it's
really funny like um yeah tim allen's in
it i think and uh sigourney weaver is in
it and uh who the [ __ ] else is in it now
i can't remember but yeah it's been a
while since i've seen it we should
probably like review that one of these
days
so you know
yeah
oracle says the computer would be a gen
xer
[Laughter]
yeah it would be like a gen x or just
quit asking me these stupid questions
it would probably tell you a different
thing every day because the situation
would be changing
it would say well this might happen or
this might it would be surmising this is
a conscious super computer you know
something has sentience
if
it would probably be as futile as asking
a a
just a living person a biological person
it would just be probably saying stuff
like well it's hard to say because so
much so much stuff can happen and this
could happen and that can happen that's
what i'm saying there's just too many
contingencies yeah it would it would it
would give you stuff like that what i
think will happen is is in a thousand
years this will happen in a hundred
years this will happen and then you ask
it the next day he goes well
[ __ ] changed
so the possibility of this happen is
gonna be less and the possibility of
this happening will be more so so you
wouldn't be able to use the information
it's given you probably no one can
predict the future even a super computer
is what i'm saying
well the thing about i think that you
know and i think one of the things that
like you know uh john barker was the
name of the psychiatrist that started
the british premonitions bureau i think
one thing that
humans in particular are fascinated by
like about premonitions and you know
fortunes and stuff like that is that
humans really have a hard time with
uncertainty they don't like um you know
not knowing what's gonna happen so
anything that promises to tell you like
some give you some certainty yeah um is
gonna make people like feel better now i
have [ __ ] done some [ __ ] that was
paranormal
in this realm
like had dreams that came true
or had feelings
that something would happen and it did
happen
um
god heard voices in my head that said
things about people that turned out to
be true
um
there if you lex friedman's got a great
show and he had a guy on there who is a
professor who is researching
consciousness
and uh
he's theorizing that consciousness is
not happening in the brain it's
happening outside the brain
in a cloud of quantum particles that are
in superposition it's basically stuart
hameroff's
quantum soul theory
well
that quantum cloud
that is causing consciousness to happen
to make you feel like you're here that
that feeling of koala like knowing what
things taste like and
which is something that a computer or a
machine will never really know oh this
tastes good that tastes bad and this
tastes like this red looks like this
it's
it doesn't feel it there's no
quality that's called koala well
whatever that is outside your brain is
in a slightly different space time
so it may have access
to what will happen outside the normal
time stream and maybe through that
indirectly you can get a message of
something that's about to happen
or
information that you couldn't know by
any other means
maybe that all animals do that and some
of that has we would call instinct
you know like ants
but ants are so small some some of those
species of ants is it just looks like a
damn black
wispy dot
if you look at that ant's brain there's
not many not many neurons there and that
thing's doing complicated
processes
whatever that whatever causes that ant
to operate as an ant and to do all those
tasks isn't physical
i think a lot of that animal is
non-physical
it's that cloud that we would call
the quantum soul now their
their cloud may not be as advanced as a
creature like a human or other higher
creatures
but it allows that insect to make
computations that the brain can't com
just isn't big enough to do
and they pointed out that the damn
hunting spiders those little bitty ones
are doing things that there's not a
brain there so how is it doing this you
know
and there's more to it there's more to
that animal in another dimension yes me
danny rowling said i've had three
precognitive dreams that came true
before with that being said it's
probably common to dream like that and
not even know it in my opinion yeah yeah
i kind of feel like forgiving your
dreams well i kind of feel like dr
barker was kind of coming at it from
that angle too maybe he was thinking
that it's actually like quite common for
people to dream like this but i think
like everybody that
was kind of studying this type of stuff
they always like encourage people to do
dream journals where you would as soon
as you would wake up like you would
write down because normally like you
know as soon as you wake up like within
15 minutes you pretty much forgot i'm
convinced we're far more complicated
than just a physical structure there's a
lot more going on in there and some of
that shit's quantum happening in the
quantum world and in dimensions slightly
adjacent to this one
ancient people called it souls or the
spirit world but nowadays you could
probably uh say no it's a slightly
higher dimension there's more of you in
that higher dimension it's quantum
particles doing things
that has access to a slightly different
spatial spacetime dimension there's
going to be ways to explain it
whatever it is it's not we're calling it
paranormal but it's not supernatural
it's a natural process we just don't
know
we don't know the react we don't really
know the true nature of of the universe
reality and and life and consciousness
they'll figure it out eventually
but um and there may be a breakthrough
one day
but there's more to us than meets the
eye
and uh
dream work and trying to go out of body
and or going out of body weird altered
states of consciousness that sometimes
you can achieve through psychedelics
um
and
some people have [ __ ] talked about
that damn what's at ayahuasca
but i s i saw a video of a guy who went
to brazil to go try out ayahuasca and he
had tried lsd and he said lsd was better
he said dmt was a lot better he didn't
recommend ayahuasca well doesn't it make
you sick yeah he said it made it real
sick and it wasn't
it didn't it wasn't as strong
he thought it was all hype
he says that if you wanted
he recommended dmt
he said that that was a lot better it
was a lot more spiritual
yeah i mean that's that's the thing even
if it is just going on in your brain
like i think there's a lot of value
there's a lot of value in
you know exploring those avenues you
don't have to take drugs yourself but
i'm just saying that there's a lot of
value in studying people's reactions to
various things like that in altered
states of consciousness jenny's never
really had an altered state years back
got her hands on some good lsd
and we dropped and jenny liked it it was
that was her first experience with it
we're not telling people to do drugs and
we're just saying what what
what she went through and it it is an
altered state of consciousness it's
weird isn't it it is very weird it's
weird it's not
intoxication like through alcohol it's
not
acceleration like through things like
cocaine or amphetamines it doesn't feel
anything like that it's um
kind of like a cross between being awake
and asleep and dreaming but you're in
total control of it over it it's not
it's not a scary experience it's very
pleasant
yeah i mean i know some people have had
scary experiences on it but the
experience i had was very very pleasant
fun yeah you just have to have a good
environment you got to be at home don't
go anywhere
yeah that's yeah and be with a person
who's experienced you know because you
want to go outside so now you're not
going outside
stay right here yeah yeah i think i told
that story before because i kind of
thought well i didn't i didn't actually
think i was a werewolf you're right she
wanted to go but digging the dirt yeah i
wanted to go roll around in the grass
but that's the weird thing about it it's
like hard to explain because it's like i
didn't actually think i was a werewolf i
knew i was made you just felt like one
but i just kind of felt like a werewolf
and i think i told you i was like i
think i'm a werewolf right
it was kind of for me
in that particular one i kind of i was
having a good time but i had to keep an
eye on her yeah um
because that was her first time and i
wasn't really sure how she was going to
react
and um i wasn't able to go inward i
wanted to just kind of cover my eyes and
lay
down and go still and just
vanish and go inward into the inner
world but i wasn't able to do it
because the situation didn't allow for
it um
i wanted to see if i could reactivate
[ __ ]
[ __ ] psychokinesis or or maybe see
the future
or get in contact with the higher
versions of the
yongi himself and
but that's something you can only do
when you're in a safe environment and
and you can focus on that i had to kind
of watch her which that's fine you know
that was part of the plan anyway
but um she could probably do it now it's
been years now but she could probably do
it now where i could trust her yeah you
know because i mean you never know what
i'm going to do
no i think i don't even know what the
hell i'm going to do
she was just having fun she's oh i see i
understand now you know let's go play
like no you can't go outside yeah camp
guy said acid makes me feel an
incredible oneness with everything yeah
yeah it's like a place in the universe
and it's funny because i you know i
remember because i was very lucid and i
remember thinking
that like when i was i was actually it
was night time because we did it like
all day and it was night time and i was
sitting by the sliding glass door in the
bedroom and me and pookie were like
sitting there like looking outside like
at the stars and i said oh my god i
understand all the [ __ ] hippies now
yeah what they're talking about what
they're talking about right like when
you know yeah i understand what they're
talking about cia was using it to uh
experimenting with using it as a as a
weapon
because there's no od points so you
could spray it out of a helicopter or
spray it out of explosive [ __ ]
artillery shells
and uh
have it land on enemy troops and just
get them high as hell and they wouldn't
fight so you could go out there and
capture them that's what the idea was
didn't quite work out that way but that
would be a good one to use because
there's no od point
uh which means you're not going to kill
them if you get too much yeah you know
um
so and then they also tried to use it
for
what's called d patterning which is
[ __ ] brutal
mk ultra was a
had an experiment going on in up in
canada
with a psychologist and he was just
taking people and putting them in dark
rooms and
filling them up full of lsd we did a
show about that they did a show about it
yeah and then electroshock treatment for
like a year to totally reduce that
person down to an infantile state
and then build them back up
de-patterning which means erasing the
mind
totally on inhumane and that and then
bring them back and make them a
different person they were trying to
make manchurian candidates but they were
using a psychiatrist
up in canada
uh where they could get away with it all
right um
they were using him as a kind of like a
research scientist as a private
contractor to erase people's minds they
were doing this to housewives that had
no problems
like depression
totally [ __ ]
uh crime against humanity they got away
with it so i do not trust these [ __ ]
do not trust cia fbi none of them guys
they're all bad they were although i
feel like it didn't really work today
great to hear yeah it was just
it kind of worked evidently just that
it's still [ __ ] torture it is yeah
yeah i'm not saying that it's like it
wasn't a big deal i'm just saying it
didn't yeah and then they took german
research from the third reich what they
were doing
they were taking
it's also part of mk ultra and [ __ ] that
came out after mk ultra and i remember
the senate hearings of with the victims
and everything of the of the girls they
were taking girls
out of
uh protective custody you know like what
are they called [ __ ] uh state
protective custody uh from like orphans
and [ __ ] yeah they were taking them
giving them a bunch of lsd electric
shock treatment these are little girls
and then sexually abusing them to get
them to form multiple personality
disorder and then train those multiple
personalities to be different things one
of them would be a sex operative the
other would be an assassin and then they
would use them
to uh get dirt on powerful men you know
it's all that island
child sex island [ __ ] they were using
that they were coming out of those
orphanages and that did happen and
they've tried to erase that but i
remember when that i remember when that
was being on tv when those girls came
forward with their lawyers to try to get
a settlement because they they survived
it or at least the ones that they did
survive evidently some of them were
killed
this is not a [ __ ] clean deal with
the with these agencies man they're
they're bad they were always bad
any anything after world war two
bad yeah they gave people some [ __ ]
ideas they were yeah and that was part
of mk ultra they were trying to make
assassins and sex operatives out of
little kids
because they couldn't use the gay thing
as an angle to get somebody to [ __ ]
talk or to control somebody they wanted
mind control
you could control somebody like remote
control you only do that if you have
leverage and dirt on them
the gay thing wasn't enough the pedo
thing worked a lot better so they wanted
to go that route
and they learned that from the nazis
the nazis were doing that their
intelligence agencies figured that out
and we brought them in during operation
paper clip this is all secret history
it's true if you dig it up and they just
try to suppress it
operation paperclip just didn't bring
rocket scientists they brought in a
bunch of other [ __ ] psychologists and
[ __ ] mind control people because mind
control is the opposite is the perfect
weapon
uh much better than nuclear power and
everything it's just because you can get
people to stop fighting
and you can win a war
because it as you've seen now if you
resist if you resist forever you win
let's
i got 85 iq dudes and flip-flops up in
afghanistan whipped our ass because they
just resisted forever
same with vietnam
if you can get him to stop resisting
through mind control
then you'll win
so my control is the [ __ ] holy grail
so that goes back to this [ __ ]
premonitions the power of the [ __ ]
mind
okay
it's the it's if you can control the
mind
your own mind in the minds of others
you're that you're the man you're the
king
all right
premonitions may be something that the
mind can do
i've i've dreamt things that came true
i've seen things that or thought things
about people that turned out to become
true and it wasn't some higher
function of being [ __ ] educated or
high iq or any other [ __ ] it was
just instinct
you know listening to things that
happened in my own mind
it's like a voice like
hey that's a bad person
and i don't know why i hear it but then
later on you find out yeah that is a bad
person
um jenny saw me do that years back i
said no no no that was it was a dude
that turned out to be a rapist
yeah never yeah he's known for that [ __ ]
now i guess i
as soon as i saw that dude [ __ ] after
about three or four exchanges in terms
of sentences i was like
nope yeah he is the creator nope
and it wasn't anything that he said it
was just
a bunch of cues
in his
delivery his body language
and i just got a signal from
one of the facets inside my mind
because there isn't one mind this is
proven
you're a multiplicity of [ __ ]
consciousnesses you're a group
inside your mind
each one of those in each one of those
little individuals is like a part of a
committee and they're all talking to
each other
and then they come up with a consensus
and they give that consensus to the
thing that you call yourself your
conscious mind
and uh
that one consciousness guy talked about
that
some of them in me are like venom or
[ __ ] the dude from the shiny jack
torrance some of them
some are good and some of them are bad
but that's with everybody wait you have
good ones i don't think yeah i got good
ones i don't think i got good ones too
i got good ones too i had sophie [ __ ]
send me a message because you know the
whole thing about venom and the [ __ ]
that thing that attacks you she's like i
got one of those also
i think like i said to a greater or
lesser degree i think most people yeah
like and i think i talked about that
before mine isn't so much
let's eat people's heads mine is more
inward turning which i think in general
is more a woman thing
women usually like
it's more of like self-hatred yeah
whereas men in general not all men
obviously tend to blame
others like they go outward whereas
women blame themselves even if they're
not responsible no mine's a mixture some
of them that's what i'm saying but
that's why i'm saying that's general the
one that's like venom
hates me
all right it tells me that i'm too weak
and that i have only survived because of
him
and that he's doing anything anything
that works in my life is because he did
it so it's just like that when i was
watching that venom movie what's what's
that british actor's name i [ __ ] love
that dude
what's that guy
that was wait was tom hardy in that tom
hardy yeah that tom hardy yeah [ __ ]
when i was watching that tom hardy movie
the venom i was like dude i know exactly
where you're coming from i got that
thing that's it
i cannot believe
i cannot believe this [ __ ] i'm gonna go
ahead and protest this now that tom hart
that they said no to tom hardy for being
the next james bond
as it's unthinkable he's been a good one
i think yeah he's already got a [ __ ]
pre-made fan base and everything we need
to call broccoli the broccoli company
and tell them that they are well i think
albert broccoli died a long time ago but
i think like the family is still yeah
they're still running it they're so
running for not for not having him as
james bond they think he was too old or
i don't understand it
that's to me tom hardy would be the
[ __ ] perfect james bond i know he's a
great actor he could do criminals good
guys
[ __ ] superheroes
maybe yeah he's great maybe they think
he's too much of a [ __ ] that he's
spread himself out too much they want
their own star to be james bond but i
think tom hardy maybe that's what it is
maybe they think he's too recognized
yeah i don't yeah but still they're but
they're yeah they're tripping they're
tripping [ __ ] because they want
somebody they can hold into the
character that's like i guess so but i
don't it's not how i'm seeing it all
right
[ __ ] um
james bond
has to be
a badass british dude
that's tom hardy he's got to be cool
he's got to be be able to fight he's got
to
beat big he's got to be a mixture of
good and bad that's [ __ ] tom hardy
man
that's the best british guy they got
going
and that's like well i mean there's a
lot of great british accents but i'd say
that's tom hardy yeah you know and and
he's got a ready-made fan base that'd be
a hit
they're just dumb not for doing that
this is interesting john smith says sam
neil got turned down for being bond in
place of timothy dalton which would have
been interesting now sam neil is
australian is he not is he australian or
new zealander
i thought that's what his accent was
uh hey dave what's up they used pierce
brosnan and he was kind of popular
that's what i'm saying it's like pierce
brosnan yeah i mean if that's their
argument it's like oh oh he's too but
pierce brosnan was on that [ __ ] tv
show right like everybody knew who the
[ __ ] knows who pierce brosnan was right
well craig was great dalton was real
good i watched the two dalton movies i
said yeah okay craig is kind of
channeling dalton
tom hardy tom hardy man what the [ __ ]
it's right there in front of your face
everybody would see that
what are you saying he's not tall enough
what's the problem
danny rowling said killian murphy yeah
he might be a good one too i don't
remember which one oh now we're getting
on change bomb yeah go put tomorrow yeah
we just did a yeah we just did a game
review do you see how this happens
everything just
everything just get this is why our
shows are [ __ ] four or five hours
long because we just keep like talking
about some other [ __ ]
okay i said i'm gonna get some ian
fleming bond books next time i don't
think i've read any of them i might have
read a couple of them when i was a
teenager because i kind of read
everything when i was a teenager but if
i did i don't really remember
them
sam neil is james bond though i'm not
really sure i see that i like samuel i'm
not saying that but they're just being
stupid or either that or it's a lie
maybe they did select tom hardy but
they're not letting anybody everybody
know yeah maybe they're like doing like
something
oracle said remember when people were
complaining that daniel craig couldn't
be bond because he's blonde yeah stupid
i wrote yeah they pissed and moaned when
he got picked too yeah but then he but
he was great so
sam neil was born in ireland was he
really
why did i think he was australian
hardy's perfect he's british he's got
physicality he's versatile
um he's got
a the right look
he's not too good looking he's good
looking but he's not too good looking
roger moore was too good he looked a
male model well see the thing about that
is that roger moore was good looking but
not sexy not sexy tom hardy is super
sexy yeah
i thought craig was too though yeah
daniel craig also super sad sexy uh beat
up looking sexy but that's what that's
the way he was described in the book
in the books he was like like a thug a
bug in a suit
which you know and this this is like a
british icon this is the british version
of batman or superman you know what i
mean [ __ ] he's got to have that right
look at tom hardy yeah [ __ ] man
i think he would be amazing he'd be
amazing if his bond i'd be all over it
because i know he could bring it he
could [ __ ] bring it to the table yeah
i'm gonna say that they're lying i'm in
denial maybe they are maybe they're
trying to like throw everybody off the
scene yeah he's not gonna he's not gonna
because it to me it's just the obvious i
put i put hardy in there yeah i mean
like i said there are a lot of good
british actors but yeah i think he would
be a really good one yeah
or maybe he doesn't want to do it maybe
no he wanted to do it oh he did yeah
he wants to be bond and i was like
that's who you want
a dude that's like that who wants to be
[ __ ] bond he'd [ __ ] bring it
he brought it to everything else
also can we talk about how awesome
bronson was bronson was [ __ ] great
that tom hardy was it yeah
that was absolutely that was such a
great great movie if you like clockwork
orange go see bronson
tom hardy it plays a [ __ ] it's like
seeing clockwork orange but it's about a
real character he was
england's fate
most famous convict and [ __ ] was
crazy a great show great show also the
one where he played the [ __ ] the
twins uh was it uh craig about the crazy
craze he [ __ ] did great on that you
know
what the [ __ ] are they i'm getting mad
talking about this okay
i'm getting mad because of course tom
hardy james bond of course
of course john smith said daniel craig
has that steve mcqueen vibe yeah has
whiskey cigars and steak for breakfast
yeah washed down with whole cream and a
punch in the face
that's right mcqueen was the [ __ ] too
the queen was the [ __ ] too bullet i
didn't see it until recently and [ __ ]
yeah i told you i was like you've got to
be [ __ ] bullied i see bullet bullet
was really good that's one of those
movies like if i feel like if you
haven't seen it like i'm gonna revoke
your dude car yeah you're gonna get your
man card
yeah [ __ ] buddy my xanada who's a
young guy [ __ ] he saw that movie on
uh based upon our um recommendation and
he's like oh yeah it's one of my
favorite movies it's like he put that up
there with [ __ ] apocalypse now
and it's just a hard-boiled
one of the first modern
cop
detective kind of action movies
grounded in reality very gritty
and the the ending is unresolved it's
one of those because it's very much like
reality like i think i did the right
thing did i win i'm not sure it's like
that kind of yeah i got away because i
kind of like yeah the bad guy got away
because he was your boss that kind of
deal
well you know it was starting to go that
way in the 1960s and 1970s where movies
were starting to be grittier more
realistic whereas before that they'd
been like more strangely in theaters and
they had a lot of realistic gunfights
realistic [ __ ] um great
driving scenes
and the gunfights were realistic because
they weren't real stylized they
were violent but
crowded in reality
it was it was a good movie gotta see
bullet i don't have that one do i no
i think we watched it on amazon yeah i
got a five bullet on blu-ray
danny rowling says what do you call a
fat psychic a fortune teller
man you were just full of the dad jokes
aren't you
i feel like i don't know any jokes
dad ones or otherwise but that's like a
pretty good one yeah so do you have
anything else you would like to get into
before we actually get into the actual
show go ahead and start i mean we did
actually kind of talk about it a little
bit at the beginning that was like an
introduction but then you know how we do
we get like [ __ ] distractions
we get distracted they're all here well
tom gets distracted
i'm just over here looking at my notes
going oh i gotta get through all those
uh yeah
uh and then they're still talking about
james bond movies holy crap
okay well all right so we're gonna start
talking about this now so yeah i'm
reading comments because otherwise we'll
get back like into the james bond thing
and we just did and we just did a james
bond review like yesterday and we're all
trying to pull this place into the world
of bond that's it which i'm gonna go
back into bond i want to see um
i have all the pierced bras and the ones
they were
okay
goldeneye was the best one
the last one wasn't that good
you know the last brosnan one i want to
go look at um
a couple of the roger moore once i never
saw a moon raker which i heard was the
cheesiest one i want to see it's pretty
[ __ ] cheap yeah that was pretty
cheesy yeah i want to see uh some of the
sean connery ones i saw them when i was
a kid but they didn't you know i was too
young to really get an impact on on them
i want to see a couple of good sean
connery ones
but i'm not sure which the good ones are
you guys can drop them in the comment
section
oh but i want to see a couple of those
um
now somebody was saying thunderball was
kind of like outside canon but it was
good
they had sean connery in it i'd like to
see that one too
yeah i think like i said over the years
i've probably seen all of them or bits
of all of them
i just don't remember which ones are
which you know what i'm saying other
than like the real iconic ones so you
know
john smith said best bond movies made
with the golden gun if only because
christopher lee is the man
okay yeah i'll see that one that's sean
connery i think
isn't it yeah i think it is yeah i can't
remember what year that came out i also
want to reseed diamonds or forever i saw
that as a kid and liked it but that was
[ __ ] 70s
kanavatsan says dude unsub never seen
moonraker
no i've never seen moonraker i saw it as
a kid and i remember it being like
pretty terrible even when i was like
but it's entertaining
the main one how bad it is the main one
i remember from roger moore was view to
a kill
well yeah i mean i had to see that one i
was i was contractually obliged to see
that one because the duran duran did the
and i loved duran duran so yeah i had
and what's her name was
[Laughter]
no man with the golden gun they said is
roger moore roger moore okay roger moore
okay
so you know
we should do we should probably do we
could probably do like a whole five-hour
show just on james bond movies well we
should re you should you should like use
some james you should like watch all of
them and then we'll like there's too
many
17 or 18 19 of them i thought that was
more than that to be honest yeah there's
too many of them i don't even know how
many there are it's a lot it's a lot and
then like you know how i do if we did
that i'd be like well i have to read a
bunch of the books too because i have to
you know how i have to do yeah i have to
get all the information you're right
because i don't want anybody coming at
me and being like hey you messed this up
or hey you messed that up so i was like
i have to know every specific thing um
yeah i said live and let die was a good
roger mark
i remember the title i didn't see it i
yeah i remember that one being okay so
mostly i remember beautiful kill and i
remember moon raker because it was like
so uh cheese ball yeah um those are the
main right moonraker was the response to
star wars
star wars came out and they had to do
he's like well james bond has to go to
space space i mean
yeah
it's kind of like friday the 13th
chasing in space although you know
everybody has to go to space you make
enough movies yeah we're goofing
we're goofing on it but evidently that
was what the audiences at the time
wanted uh that they didn't know anything
well they were big
they were big
put ons really the shows you know i mean
like it was they were considered to be
kind of goofy fun
shows that were
had big scope and a lot of adventure
we're going down [ __ ] double seven
again but uh
that's just that was kind of evidently
what the audiences wanted at the time
yeah they were just like
popcorn movies that you went you had a
good time you watched james bond do
[ __ ] ridiculous [ __ ] and laughed and
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah oh that's cool then
you left
because uh when i saw the dalton ones
and some of the
very last roger moore ones you know when
i was up in when i was in brazil as a
kid that's how i felt at the time i was
like oh yeah yeah oh that's great you
know what i mean and then you leave the
theater and then you're like oh yeah
okay i'm gonna get high you could smoke
smoke so wait that was just you know
like look at that [ __ ] he just
like he had a tuxedo on underneath his
wetsuit exactly exactly and he showed up
in the casino and his hair was all
perfect yeah and he came up to the sewer
he didn't even stink
yeah how funny would it have been if
like everybody was like
yeah he's like like
yeah
what the hell dude
or he could have like well i know this
is an anachronism but it would have been
funny if he'd like come out of there and
then sprayed himself with febreze or
something
[Laughter]
a girl can dream right it's like
that would have been really funny all
right so um
okay danny rowling has another dad joke
what's the best thing about fingering a
psychic while she's on her period you
get your palm read for free
[Music]
i actually kind of like that one
come on who doesn't love dad jokes we
love dad jokes all right so
as i mentioned earlier british
premonitions bureau i had never heard of
this thing before before chat told me
about it
me personally
and although i will say that i had heard
about the disaster which uh which the
catalyst for it which is what i'm going
to talk about right now
so
the disaster that happened that brought
the idea of the british premonitions
bureau into being
was the abrahavan disaster now i've
actually been to abervand it's in wales
uh because where i lived was not too far
from there i think it was only five or
six miles away from where i was living
at the time uh and it's
going there is like really
creepy because like you read about it
um and a bunch of people died and i'm
gonna get into it but it's like now it's
like this big cemetery and like when you
go there you really get a sense of like
oh my god that is so many people i mean
this wasn't like a
i mean this was like a pretty small
village right and they lost like a
couple like you know 116 people
something like that like in one day and
most of them were children and it was
just like really horrifying
so seeing like all the graves and stuff
because it's like like i said it's like
this big cemetery there is like really
really
creepy like it really got it got to me
so i have been to abraham i've been to
martha tidbill i've been to big tip i've
been to all that stuff i've been down in
the coal mine and everything
it was like a long time ago but i've
been there
so the aberban disaster is what
gave
uh
what gave john barker the psychiatrist
behind this the idea for the british
premonitions bureau so what the aprivan
disaster was if you don't know
uh back in october of 1966
there was um
a colliery spoil tip
in uh this little town called abravan
now uh the tip
you know because if you have a coal mine
you have like a lot of waste product
right so they would usually like
um you know put it kind of up in a
mountain actually the town where i lived
in wales there was a mountain in the
middle like of the two towns and it was
almost all like old coal slurry and they
were trying to like get rid of it like
slowly you know what i mean because they
didn't really have coal mines anymore
like they'd mostly been closed in the
80s so
uh this tip which had all this stuff uh
was on a slope above uh abervan
which is near uh martha tedville big uh
cold mining town
and it was kind of on top of a natural
spring which you're not really supposed
to do for this exact reason
now there had been a period of heavy
rain leading up to this i believe it had
been raining a lot for like three weeks
prior to the disaster happening
and on this particular morning which was
october 21st 1966
um
the water in the tip had built up to
such an extent that it essentially all
slid downhill as coal slurry
uh and it went over a school
which had just started classes for the
day
and over 18 houses
so it ended up killing 116 children and
28 adults
now uh the town of abervan actually had
seven spoil tips uh tip seven was the
one that uh went into the village they
had started that back in 1958. uh at the
time of the disaster when it slid down
the mountain it was 111
feet high
now as i said uh actually after the
disaster happened the national coal
board like got on the case uh or they
actually got uh in trouble and they a
bunch of people got fired and blamed for
it because you're not really supposed to
put like a coal tip
on top of a natural water spring but
this one was so not only had it been
raining for three weeks but it also had
like a spring underneath it so the all
the coal story had had become
essentially or you know the coal waste
had become
saturated with water and it all just
like suddenly slid down uh at once
so it was about 110 000 square or cubic
meters rather
cubic i said
they'd say
okay are you are you nine i'm just like
cubic i said
cubic meters
or 140 000 cubic yards of coal slurry
that came down on this town
uh and as i said the school was the main
i mean a bunch of buildings were hit 18
uh houses were destroyed also but the
local junior school was the main
building that was hit and 116 kids were
in there and were killed yeah basically
they said it sounded like you know
people that survived which was not very
many um but they said yeah it sounded
like a jet plane all of a sudden and
then they were just all buried like it
happened in which is
horrifying imagine that
damn so 144 people 144 people wiped out
just wiped out in a morning it was just
and they were all [ __ ] dead yeah
there was times where that's crazy
that's
there was a flood that happened in the
united states back in the 1800s if um
man i remember all the details now i
think it was some kind of a dam that
broke
and it wiped out an entire town with
thousands of people in one day back in
the late 1800s
remember that town i i think i i might
have brought it up on one of the other
shows but you remember there was i think
this happened back in the 1800s but you
remember the town was it god was it in
baltimore or i feel like it was
somewhere like up in the northeast some
place where um the town flooded with
molasses
do you remember that i remember that one
yeah yeah it was just kind of i don't
remember how many people died but it was
kind of famous i mean it's still kind of
famous that it's like i think it was
like the molasses plant that was in town
or something like that like some
horrible
cataclysm happened and there was like
this big molasses so much [ __ ] from
granted in in the modern era
you know what i mean i mean
can you imagine back in the day you
could just be minding your own business
and then the next thing you know your
entire [ __ ] town wiped out from
existence because i mean it could still
happen you know like a meteor could land
on your [ __ ] or something you didn't
just leave a crater yeah but
i don't know i kind of feel like and you
know honestly just on an individual
level you could just be minding your own
business and again like a meteor could
fall kind of obsessed with meteors as
you can see like a meteor could just
come through the roof and like fall on
you and kill you or you could just be
walking down the street and a bus could
hit you or some [ __ ] like that i don't
know cookie walked up and asked you for
treats
i don't there's something there's some
in your snowman baby
yes i put some in your snowman
she was mad because i had to order more
treats because we're almost out she
wouldn't
and her
her snacky the snowman was empty for
like
six hours and that was like clearly too
much yeah she's like knocking it around
and no treats are coming out like
she's like what the [ __ ] it's like give
it up snacky and i was just kind of like
so i had to put some more in there but i
had to like show her that that was like
in there because she's down there she
gets mad when she hits snacky and no
snacky's a little round ball that looks
like he's a little snowman with a hole
in it you put treats in it when she sits
it [ __ ] comes flying out yeah
yeah that's why it's naki that was well
that's the name of it that's its name
that's why i call it that like i got her
that for christmas it came with like the
little snowman and it came with a little
packet of treats and she loves that
thing she goes over there pretty much
every day and like smacks him around and
like waits
waits for the little treats to come on
his butt but like i said we're running
low on treats i got some more coming
tomorrow but okay
but i put some in there i see you but
when it gets empty she gets like real
upset so so yeah i mean all these little
kids
you know i don't even know like what the
population of this town was at this time
period but
116 kids i mean it was 144 people but
like 116 kids i mean it was like pretty
much everybody in that village
had to have known somebody that was
killed or you know what i mean so
i just can't even imagine and like i
said i've been to abervan and i've
looked at the
you know the massive cemetery there and
it's really really upsetting it's really
upsetting to like look at it
um but yeah so 18 houses destroyed all
those people died everything like that
now as soon as it happened
i mean
obviously everybody flipped out um
but everybody like everybody in the
surrounding area like immediately came
there to help um you know they had like
miners come and like all kind of
volunteers and stuff like that and came
and like had to start trying to dig
people out like they didn't know if
people were still alive in there or like
dig out the bodies or whatever so they
had like all these people come there and
like start digging people out
um they put out calls for like rubber
gloves because they're like they needed
help digging and like people sent like 6
000 pairs people spent like millions and
millions of pounds like you know all
over the country so everybody really
kind of like pulled together uh because
of this disaster prime minister who was
harold wilson at the time uh he came
there too and they were still like
pulling bodies out of the rubble which
is like i said [ __ ] horrible
so the psychiatrist uh that we're
talking about who's kind of like the
center of the story that we're talking
about today his name is john barker
now he was one of the ones that came to
abervan to
help out because like i said they were
looking for volunteers and stuff like
that uh at the time he was 42 years old
now his main interest was
weird
mental conditions that was kind of like
his area of expertise uh i believe his
uh he'd written kind of his um you know
what what do they call that when you're
to get your degree or whatever the uh
dissertation his dissertation yeah i
believe he'd written that on uh
munchausen syndrome okay so he was like
really interested in like weird like i
said like weird
psychiatric conditions
now at the time he was actually
interested and maybe one of the reasons
he came there not just to help but he
was writing a book at the time which i
think is called scared to death
and he was researching a book about
what he called psychic death i've also
seen other psychiatrists prior to him
call it voodoo death
um
basically people who
kind of will themselves into die this is
kind of like if somebody if you actually
believe that somebody put a voodoo curse
on you for example
how that might become a self-fulfilling
prophecy so he was actually kind of
interested in that
and one of the reasons that he came to
abrahavan was that he heard
that a boy had actually like escaped
from the coal slurry
but had died of freight subsequently i
don't know if that's true or not
but he had heard that and he's like oh
that sounds like you know my area of
expertise or my area of research so i'm
interested to like go and check that out
so he gets to this to the site like
people are still being dug out like from
underneath the coal slurry and he said
it was horrifying he said it looked like
the [ __ ] blitz from world war ii
right he said it was just like that
now while he was there um he started
hearing people's kind of chatter like
people talking
and he said he heard more than one
family talking about
weird dreams they had had prior to this
happening and like weird omens stuff
like that
so as he started like asking around
he found out that one eight-year-old kid
named paul davis
according to his parents presumably
uh the day or the night before
the disaster
he had drawn a picture
of a bunch of people
like little uh you know stick figures
digging in the hillside
and there was like it was kind of all
black
and then underneath it said the end
and he had drawn that like the night
before
and paul davis the kid actually ended up
dying in this particular uh disaster
there was also another little girl who
was 10 and her name was errol may jones
and apparently according to her mother
two weeks before the disaster she had
told her mom
just out of the blue that she was not
afraid to die
and the day before the disaster
she said to her mom i want to tell you
about a dream i had last night and the
mom was like yeah i don't really have
time right now tell me later
and then the kid said no uh you have to
listen to me i dreamt that i went to
school and there was no school there
something black had come down all over
it
now as far as i know she also went to
school she didn't want to go to school
that day but her mom made her and um
that's i think that's kind of what i
heard anyway and that she also ended up
dying in the disaster now as i said at
this point
barker's just like interested but i mean
it could be that
you know you're just going on somebody's
say-so or somebody's
words maybe you know they could be
making more out of it than
than is uh you know
but you know so
barker was actually even though he was a
psychiatrist and he'd like published in
the lancet like he was a very well
respected medical professional
but
he had ever since he was a kid he'd been
very very interested in paranormal stuff
um but he didn't really make a big issue
out of it i guess because he thought
people would make fun of him or not
taking him seriously or anything like
that
but he was a member of the society for
psychical research
that's a well-known organization yeah i
mean yeah the british one has been
around since the late 1880s uh they have
an american one too which was uh formed
a few years later yeah it's kind of like
[ __ ]
the real time the the real life version
of uh [ __ ] the league of
kind of extraordinary gentlemen
was it was dudes that were kind of like
um
they were investigators that would
i don't want to call them debunkers they
were investigators but
a lot of them ended up being debunkers
really yeah well because a lot of was
the same thing yeah a lot of the [ __ ]
was fake yeah and i think we talked
about that that someone we were talking
about right spiritualism and seance
issue because i've always been
fascinated by
um
the way like that a lot of people like
faked seance stuff and then the british
had their own way of [ __ ] doing all
this stuff
having societies that come in and
investigating [ __ ] because that's cool
that's cool i think it was most of the
vocabulary
uh that made it seem well they took it
seriously seriously that they actually
said well maybe there is something they
were open-minded enough to say maybe
there is something worth looking into
but they weren't so
they weren't so open-minded as they say
that their brains fell out right
so they were willing to like take a
scientific approach to which is totally
fair particularly back in that time
period because it was a lot of stuff
they still didn't understand about
what's going on
so um he had actually written a paper
barker had for the
society for secular research
and he was kind of like and i think he
wrote this a little bit later he's like
look um
even if people had
had a you know a premonition that this
was gonna happen
you know who would they report it to
like how
you know how would we
take action from that you know what i'm
saying um you know it's like you people
have premonitions you wouldn't know like
i said if you were just going by the
little girl saying my school was all
black or something like that or the
little boy that drew the thing it's like
well
you know that's kind of but it's kind of
clearer in hindsight but like if you're
just like trying to predict stuff ahead
of time it's not really clear enough to
like be actionable information so he was
kind of like talking about how that was
sort of like problematic and he's like
you know there wouldn't there's really
no mechanism for reporting it to
higher authorities so something could
get done about it even if the
information was
concrete enough that we could act upon
it so he was kind of talking about that
so what he decided to do
because of this
what he saw as like maybe a weakness or
flaw in the system he's like what i
think i'm going to do just it to see if
there's something to this
he decided that he was going to start
collecting
premonitions if people had had
premonitions about abervan like before
it had happened from across
the uk
so he knew this guy named peter fairley
who was the science correspondent at
that time for uh the evening standard
which was a paper in london uh which
kind of had which had like a pretty
large circulation at that
point and he's like and i want to
i want you to write an article about it
where i'm like asking people to like
write to me if they had premonitions or
dreams or whatever like about this kind
of stuff before it happened because i'm
kind of curious
so a week after the disaster
um
fairly published a column he had a
column called world of science
and he basically asked did anyone have a
genuine premonition before the cold tip
fell on abravan
um this that's what a senior british
psychiatrist would like to know
so
what ended up happening was i mean we'll
get into that a little bit later but i
kind of want to get into a little a
little bit about barker's history
because
you know how he
sort of like balanced his
medical life with his
paranormal kind of stuff because he was
kind of an interesting person
now
at this point in time this is the 1960s
i kind of feel like a lot of britain's
mental hospitals were still very
victorian they were kind of like using a
lot of methods that obviously would be
horrifying by modern standards
um what barker was working on at the
time of the disaster he worked at a
place called shelton hospital
and
his big thing was aversion therapy
so he would do uh electroshock therapy
which is you know that's another thing
but i mean he did a little bit more
humane electroshock therapy but it's
still electroshock therapy uh and he
would also use
drugs that make you sick like to try to
like keep you from like the ludovico
technique and clockwork orange
essentially where it's just kind of like
we're gonna try and like
make you not want to do things by making
you feel ill is basically what he
doesn't work
no but that's what he was working on and
that was kind of like kind of ahead of
its time yeah it was very cutting edge
back then no no it doesn't work yeah but
um
but yeah they didn't know they had to
find out yeah
uh he actually apparently according to
the new yorker he had a slot machine
installed outside his office
which if you pulled the lever it gave
you a 70 volt shock
[Laughter]
just for shits and giggles he just
wanted to see if people would do it wow
quit touching my [ __ ]
and yeah so pretty much
so yeah but i mean he'd been kind of in
the papers and stuff like that um and he
claimed that the aversion therapy worked
at least for things that people would
come to him like oh i'm screwing around
my wife or adultery or things like that
so he's trying to like
you know keep people from doing
bad things or vices or whatever by going
about it like that
um
but
according to a lot of his co-workers and
things like that
he kind of had i get he was an
interesting person like i said because
he was very i don't want to say
emotionally volatile because that sounds
like he was a rage monster but i think
that he was very prone to
uh stress anxiety depression that kind
of stuff because he had previously
worked at a mental hospital in dorset
and it had something like a nervous
breakdown like in his 30s
um which was apparently kind of a big
deal but he did end up getting this job
at shelton later on so shelton at the
time that he
worked there i mean it had been built in
1843
um at the time that he worked there
there were about 750 patients in it and
a lot of the people that worked there
were older like their families had
worked there for a really long time
um there was another psychiatrist who
worked there with him named david enoch
and
uh he had worked there for about a year
and then i think that uh barker came the
following year now him and enoch were
both kind of like more into modern
techniques so they were very into we
need to modernize the mental health like
infrastructure in the uk because it's
still very victorian so what they were
trying to do was they were trying to
they still wanted to do
electroconvulsive therapy but
they wanted to
i mean prior to this they would still do
electroconvulsive therapy electroshock
therapy but they would do it without
drugs or painkillers or anything like
that so they're like okay we still want
to do it but we at least want to like
give people drugs so it's not so like
upsetting for them
um and they also did little things like
you know not locking the patient's doors
unless they were super dangerous um you
know giving them their own space like
they'd have their own uh little cabinets
and things where they could put their
things in it so they felt more like it
was a house rather than like at a
hospital kind of thing so a little bit
more i don't know like just a little bit
more humane i guess than the uh
hospitals had been up to that point
um and he was also pretty adamant that
a lot of the hospitals i mean he even
wrote a paper for the lancet which was
like the you know it still is as far as
i know like the uh kind of most
respected like british medical journal
um
that a lot of hospitals were kind of
like abusing their power
um you know so and it was a it was a big
enough deal that he actually got
summoned by the ministry of health to
talk about like what he had found out
my buddy grant is in there saying that
tracy the bell had a nervous breakdown
tracing the bell was a girl we went to
high school with is my uh buddy's
girlfriend yeah she went [ __ ] nuts
i remember when that happened yeah it
was weird well i mean it happens to
people yeah i don't think she totally
recovered as a matter of fact uh grandpa
shelby's photographs of what she looks
like now i'm just like god i can't
believe that we're the same age
it's just
mental illness will uh really affect how
life
treats you
yeah i mean
both on the end of if you're mentally
ill you don't always like take care of
yourself and also people treat you
differently
and those two things like really affect
how you look
and how you feel so yeah
so these two guys like i said they were
kind of on the cutting edge of you know
mental health at the time and they were
both really interested in as i mentioned
like very very strange
uh you know mental health you know
rare disorders i guess and i mentioned
that uh barker was really into like
munchausen syndrome um and there was
also stuff like i didn't even know this
thing existed but there is something
called i'm not sure if i'm pronouncing
it right but it's kuvod syndrome
syndrome
um
and it's defined as uh in which a man
seems to experience pregnancy at the
same time as his partner
what i can see how that would happen
i'm pregnant too well i guess it's kind
of like a sympathetic i get that is this
this is does this [ __ ] belly i'm
imagining that it's some kind of maybe
it might manifest itself physically
which is fascinating
that's fascinating never heard of it i
mean i had heard of what they call
hysterical pregnancies where women who
aren't pregnant they have all the
symptoms of pregnancy so i don't see why
that would be strange that it would
happen to a man sometimes i'm sure it
probably i mean well no i mean i imagine
it'd probably be rarer
um but
i mean
the mechanism there would be
yeah but you know well you're not
actually pregnant you're just having the
i mean you know
man placebo effects are a thing and
honestly like your mental state is like
pretty powerful it can't overcome
everything but depending on the person
if you really did if you really were
that
sympathetic or in
like thing with your partner like maybe
that would happen that's some weird [ __ ]
because the hormones are totally
different
but i don't think like i said i don't
think hormones have anything to do with
it i just kind of think like it's
probably the symptoms of it i had to see
what you would i have to see photographs
of what you're talking about with
because it's not i mean you wouldn't
need hormones necessarily for like for
example for like your belly to swell up
or to have like morning sickness for
example or something like that that you
wouldn't need hormones for that because
that a man could experience yeah without
being photographing that man is he
really swollen up
is he real you know or or is it just
a psychosomatic thing where he thinks
he's swollen up and he thinks he's got
morning sickness i'd have to see it
i have to see it myself yeah i'm not
real sure because like i said i imagine
it's probably vanishingly rare but i
mean it's it's not that rare because
they named it because y'all y'all know
me i'm into [ __ ] hormones and all
kinds of [ __ ] you can take a woman
you give her enough testosterone 100
milligrams a [ __ ] week for a couple
months she will turn into a man
beard everything voice attitude
everything it shall be a man but without
a dick
you know
it'll take a while
you can kind of do that with a man the
other in the other direction so i'd like
to see what it is that you know what i
mean there's a big difference between
feeling like something and actually
looking like something you know what i
mean
uh go look at blair white blair white's
transsexual
she's biologically male
you see photographs of her you know what
i mean you'd never know that that was
biological male it looks like a female
but it's surgery and the lines are very
thin between
uh no they're not that thin [ __ ]
they're the hormones are really well
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying hormones do it it doesn't take
much
now once a male
who's gone through male puberty
if they want to transition to female
the transition isn't going to look real
convincing uh with hormones alone it'll
help
then they get
reconstructions they change the eyes the
eye folds a little bit
they'll do the nose a little bit because
those male hormones
change your features permanently
adam's apple and all that but that all
can be reduced with with with surgery
the best i've seen was when i've grown
up in brazil
when all those hormones are available
basically over the counter
is uh
male to female transition
pre-pubescent
because they never went through male
puberty
and i mean it's a 12 year old 13 year
old guy who starts taking all this [ __ ]
and when by the time they're 14 15 16
you can't tell look at girls they are
girls biologically
or chemically or hormonally that's what
you want to call it
not biological but you know hormonally
they are girls physically they are girls
with the exception of just you know one
thing of course you know
you're not gonna change that dick it's
gonna be there but and that was common
in brazil
so
it's weird because america's grappling
with the [ __ ] now and they have [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] but south and central america
it's common
but there isn't any restrictions on
hormones you can buy them over the
counter
camp guys said i used to think my wife
was lucky because she got to experience
the one thing a man can never know
carrying a baby i was with her every
step but i never had any sympathetic
physical symptoms just mental yeah it's
like i don't know like i
i'm sure like some women enjoy it um you
know what i mean but i just it never
sounded like a fun time to me
my mom was into it but you know she had
four but
i don't know it just never really
sounded all that fun to me yeah the only
girl that we knew from the goth scene
that was into having kids
would be aurora she's had a bunch of
kids
she looks great too [ __ ] uh for a
woman that's had two kids
and
um the one that was uh a [ __ ] mini
me's little buddy a little redhead she's
had a bunch of kids
um she doesn't come out anymore though
because she's being a mom yeah uh will
you remember her name
no okay i'm not really married
i'll either come to me but you know the
alcohol and the head injuries are
getting me
but um grampher said granthar
impregnated his hottie wife twice never
had a single symptom except for the
lactating nips
hold on you was lactating he was
lactating i've heard that yeah i've
heard that that happens i don't think
that's unusual i mean i'd have to look
it up like but i'm pretty sure that's
not that i know
it's a trip i thought it wasn't that
unusual god damn it's a cop [ __ ]
making milk
you should have taken a video for that
man [ __ ] make money with that
gay seem to be all over that
i imagine there's probably a sub
genre yeah of porn yeah gay lactation
make all kinds of money well because
they're a straight lactation big yeah
yeah that's like a massive like point
that's a massive fetish gay lactation
would be even [ __ ] more [ __ ] uh
you make all kinds of money you'd have
been [ __ ] a unicorn with that [ __ ]
like i said i'm not dressed up in your
cop your cop outfit with your gun and
[ __ ]
squeeze them [ __ ] nipples and [ __ ]
[ __ ] go flying
you make all kinds of money
see this is how one thing that i
mentioned and he just goes off on some
completely different tangents
half naked you says caught y'all live
finally oh i'm glad you did yeah
i mean you know we're usually we're on
all the time but it's usually around the
same and you know people in different
time zones i know it's like harder for
us to harder for y'all to like catch us
live but you know we're here
um all right so where was i we got
distracted by the whole uh
men experiencing pregnancy thing
so uh so barker and enoch were
friends because they were cause like i
said they were both kind of interested
in the same kind of stuff like weird
psychiatric disorders and they were both
kind of on the cutting edge of mental
health in the uk at the time
um so they would talk all the time but
enoch said that barker never really
mentioned that he was really into
paranormal stuff probably because he'd
been burned before like he'd told people
hey i'm really into like the occult and
the paranormal and people are like
okay and you call yourself a scientist
but it was probably that kind of
situation so enoch said like until later
he didn't really know that like barker
was super into paranormal stuff and the
reason that he was into paranormal stuff
i feel like a lot of it kind of probably
came from his childhood because john
barker's dad
he was an accountant and he said that
his dad was like very very grounded very
uh he called him a matter of fact you
know he was just like a regular very
realistic uh dude
um he served in the first world war and
it had supernatural experiences which he
was completely serious about so i think
that maybe affected
i don't know i i kind of feel like that
may be affected barker's thing where he
was just kind of like oh well here's
this dude who's been in world war one
he's very uh you know math oriented he's
very logic oriented and yet he still
says you know seriously that he's had
these paranormal experiences so maybe
there's something to it
um so he was like really interested in
the paranormal like he went to borley
rectory which we did a show about which
i think was complete [ __ ] i think it
was a um i think it was a hoax but he
did go ghost hunting there
um
he uh
you know would go to like various
haunted places uh and would like try to
talk to ghosts and stuff he was like
real real into it um him and his wife
even i've had an allegedly paranormal
experience uh you know before they got
married like when they met her in the
40s you know they said they saw like
they were in this place it was supposed
to be haunted and like the doors closed
and like nobody like flew open and
closed and like they didn't you know
when no one was there stuff like that
now uh so what got him interested though
in
in the thing that sort of like
interested him about abervan
he read about this case in 1965.
um there was a case that was written up
in the british medical journal or bmj
about a woman in canada she was 43 years
old now she's not named in the paper
she's just called mrs a.b
and she was admitted to a hospital
to get like very very minor surgery she
was having problems with uh incontinence
so they were doing like a um a very
minor surgery like on her vaginal wall
because it was some kind of like leakage
or something like that so they're like
it wasn't any big deal nothing
so she's gonna do that
they did the surgery it was done in an
hour
now when she came out of the anesthesia
she started complaining about pain on
her left side and she went into shock
her blood pressure dropped and she died
now they did a postmortem they did an
autopsy on her
and they said that she'd suffered an
adrenal hemorrhage
failure the adrenal glands which is
apparently very very rare
but otherwise there was nothing else
wrong with her like i said she was only
in her early
40s now when the doctors were kind of
like mystified like what the [ __ ]
happened to this woman there's
absolutely shouldn't that shouldn't have
happened uh they found out that this
woman
uh when she was a kid
a fortune teller had told her that she
would die when she was 43 years old
and she had had a birthday the previous
week
and before the surgery she had told a
nurse and her sister i'm not going to
survive this surgery hold on one second
and she didn't
how do the how did they know
that a fortune teller she must have told
like some people and then they
imagine that when they because this was
written up in like a british medical
journal so i'm imagining they backed
their [ __ ] up so i gotta tell you truth
i've been to some fortune tellers over
the years some of them were in clubs
they told me all kinds of [ __ ] and i
can't remember what the fortune teller
told me
you know what i mean and i wouldn't have
told it to anybody else
later on i just kind of
makes me think
well no but i mean the thing about it is
that if a fortune teller because
normally i kind of feel like if you're
just going to a fortune teller like you
know wherever like i went to one in
cassadago with my mom and my aunts just
for shits and giggles yeah
if you're going to one normally they
keep it pretty feel good yeah you're
going to meet the love of your life
you're going to make some money you're
going to do this and that don't be okay
i mean if you go to a psychic and
they're like [ __ ] you're going to die i
mean you're going to like lose a lot of
your clientele nobody wants that
nobody wants that kind of like bummer to
ride that so
um
but i don't know like apparently she had
somebody's like i said she must have
told somebody at some point because
that's like the doctors found out but
whatever it was
um barter got fascinated by this case
yeah i went to a psychic in if you don't
know in florida there's a spiritualist
town
called cassadaga and there's like a
whole bunch i mean normal people live
there too but there's like a whole bunch
of psychics and stuff so if you're into
like what
no you can't go in there
she has been wanting to go in that
closet all [ __ ] day long there is
nothing in that closet please don't let
her in there
no she's not allowed to go in that
closet boy she's demanded
pookie there's nothing in there i
promise no she's like oh there's all
this good [ __ ] you guys are hiding from
me like don't yell at her just i just
slapped my hands and she ran away i
don't know why she wants to go in there
so bad she's been doing that like all
day today not being crazy now she's
coming over here
it's okay
you don't need to go in the closet you
remember what happened last time you
went in there yeah come here
she got strangled on my bra that's why i
don't let her in there yes [ __ ] man
that's a good way to go no it's not
don't say that about bulky come here
uh but yeah so
whatever the case like barker was really
interested in this story because he's
like oh well
could that mean that like people that
had premonitions or were told
by an alleged fortune teller like when
they would die
does that can that somehow like make it
a self-fulfilling prophecy and you
actually will die at that point
so he was like that was kind of like his
area of interest as aries and he was
working on a book about it like while um
when abervan happened
now he also had his own personal
experience because he said he had
treated a couple of guys
um you know during his career
who
he thought um
had had a similar situation where they
were just like so anxious like oh my god
i'm gonna die i'm gonna die and it
actually like made them die so he was
like really interested in it
um as i said he wasn't the first person
to look into this kind of stuff back in
the 1940s there was another guy who uh
at harvard
who uh called it voodoo death but he was
mostly he wasn't talking about like
quote unquote modern societies he was
kind of more into
talking about quote-unquote primitive
societies like voodoo curses and stuff
like that so that was kind of his area
of expertise but barker believed that
the same mechanism whatever it was might
also apply to
uh modern people as well that there may
be some kind of biological
mechanism behind this kind of thing
where people actually feel like they're
gonna die at a specific time then maybe
they would
so he actually wrote to the doctors in
canada who had written about this woman
that had died after the surgery and they
exchanged like a whole bunch of letters
because he was like really interested in
the case and he was really into
maybe looking into
precognition esp stuff like that that
maybe modern psychiatry could should be
looking along those lines because there
might be something to it
what um what i'm gonna make it a drink
oh i thought you were gonna like say
something because you look like you were
gonna say something okay i got pookie
down here if i could try to get me to
interact with her
what's the matter
i don't know why she wants to get in
that closet so bad there is literally
nothing in there she wants attention
there's literally because she's been
trying to get in there all day she keeps
like going by the door being like hey
and i'm like no you're not allowed to go
in there i don't know
i don't let her go in there anymore
and if you let her go in the club
because sometimes tom will let her go in
the closet in the bedroom because
there's nothing dangerous in there but
you have to be careful because if you
let her go in there
and then she'll stay in there like all
day and hide like way in the back in the
dark and like then you'll close the door
like thinking she's not in there and
then she'll just be in there for like
six or seven hours and then like later
on you hear
like hey let me out i've been sleeping
in here all day long i don't know why
she loves closets so much
so yeah so barker was really interested
in
fortune tellers as i said i kind of feel
like most fortune tellers probably just
give you good news because you know they
want to make money just like everyone
else does so i don't imagine there'd be
too much money in like telling everybody
how they're gonna die you know what i
mean
um but barker was kind of interested in
that though it's like what if you what
if you are a fortune teller just for the
sake of argument what if you're a
fortune teller or psychic or whatever
and you have a client who comes in and
you have a
premonition of their death
should you tell them how do you tell
them um he's he was kind of interested
in that kind of thing
so him and uh fairly that got the
evening standard they kind of got
together and they had like this big
dinner party and they invited like all
these psychics and astrologers and [ __ ]
like that
um
you know and fairly was gonna write an
article about it
so barker started interviewing these
fortune tellers about
you know have you ever forecast a
client's death for example
um you know how did that go
and do you think that
you know there's any uh
value in studying esp or precognition in
regards to medicine is there something
we could do about that
now
the thing that's interesting about this
though
is that
and this might have contributed because
some weird [ __ ] happens to the end this
might have contributed to something that
happened because it almost ended up like
the [ __ ] that he was studying almost
like it seemed like it happened him in
real life
so one of the things that he did perhaps
unwisely i don't even believe in
psychics and i don't even think that i
would do this myself
but he was so interested in psychics and
like them predicting people's deaths
like having premonitions of people's
deaths
that he actually
sought out fortune tellers and was like
tell me how i'm gonna die
like i don't
i don't know i kind of feel like most
people probably wouldn't do that i mean
props to him for being for having like
the commitment to his scientific
theories
that he was interested enough to
actually tell these people
uh he went to like 12 different ones
and he said please predict the date and
cause of my death
you know yeah um like i said i'm not i
don't even believe in psychics and i
don't even know if i would do that i'm
not gonna attempt fate you know what i'm
saying
but um
most of them were like nah bro we're not
doing that um because you know there's
there's really no percentage in it for
them i don't blame them
uh one of them said okay i'll do it
as it turned out uh this person was
wrong
but in the course of this experiment uh
there were some psychics that kind of
impressed him with some of their
observations although
not really knowing in depth what the
observations were they sound very
vague to me like oh um you know you have
like four of them told them oh you have
like a
this big division between your work and
your hobby which he took to me and oh my
scientific endeavors and the occult
paranormal stuff which like i said
that's vague enough that that could kind
of apply to anything uh one of the
psychics however did know that he had a
nervous breakdown uh before like at the
old mental hospital before he had moved
to the new job so there was that
um but the other stuff like i said
seemed kind of like lame like standard
[ __ ]
psychic [ __ ] kind of stuff
so as i mentioned uh a week after the
abervan disaster
uh when they published the ad in the
paper said hey did anybody have any
premonitions about this happening we
want to hear about them
so
they got 76 replies
and some of the replies there was a guy
who was from uh lancashire
and he was 63 and he said that two
nights before
the coal tip had uh
had collapsed
he dreamed that he was trying to buy a
book
and that he was looking at this big
machine that had buttons on it he said
he thought it might be a computer but he
wasn't sure
on the screen of this alleged computer
there were letters on it that said
abervan but he said that he had never
heard that word before
um so he had remembered that so he wrote
that in and this was two nights so he
said before it happened
uh another person who was in plymouth
bef the evening before like the night
before
um she was at a spiritualist meeting and
it had what she called a vision so i
guess it wasn't a dream
she apparently told six people at this
meeting
uh you know according that i guess she
had people backing her up on it
she said that she had seen a vision that
was a schoolhouse
a welsh minor and what she called an
avalanche of coal hurtling down a
mountainside toward a little boy like
with long hair
so she said she had that the night
before like i said we're just going on
what people are saying here so i don't
know if these people are just full of
[ __ ] or what it whatever because this is
like a week later
um apparently there was also a guy who
was uh 30 and he was like a film
technician he was in middlesex and he
like right when it happened according to
other people who worked with him that he
jumped up out of uh that actually was a
woman she jumped up out of her chair and
said that she smelled death like a
decaying smell and like some people said
that and that was like right when it
happened hold on one second hold on
there's a funny comment here [ __ ]
joe nash says i just came in what the
[ __ ] is this cops lactating and he's
laughing and i said yeah yeah you missed
that's what happens on this show yeah
that's what happens
my boy grabbed his hammer i went to high
school with him he's he's a s cop he's a
retired cop
he said that when he got his wife
pregnant he started lactating and he
would use the pump to save it and feed
the baby
i mean
he was [ __ ] that didn't happen
i just played along with i just played
along i know him he although like i said
i have heard of that happened yeah he's
[ __ ] i have heard of that
and i said you should have made money
with that in in the [ __ ] gay porn
scene dress up in your cop outfit with
your [ __ ] pistol and your [ __ ]
your [ __ ] pistol belt on
and [ __ ] lactate you'd make all kinds
of money all kinds of money
gay lactation
this show man it's like thank you thank
you jeffy art
it's like we can start out talking about
uh a horrible
cold tip disaster and premonitions and
end up talking about lactating cops like
okay so let me go ahead and
how does it happen now is a commercial
break we're gonna [ __ ] uh we're gonna
uh sell some shirts this is the new
shirt design i have
it's canon
studios
okay
if you drop a super chat in of 20 bucks
do your name and
[ __ ] i'll send it to you for 20 bucks
whatever i mean you'll have to like
contact me later with your
address and size and all that
and it might be a little while because i
gotta order blank shirts if we don't
yeah we may not have your size that
might take a few more [ __ ] days to
order that but um i have the screen
ready
for canon and i have the uh a lot of
shirt sizes ready for male and female
shirts
uh but i'm ready to go with canon
20 super chat and i'll send you a canon
shirt
just go ahead and put it in what's up
what is she doing is she still being bad
yeah she's being bad of course she's
being bad she's always being bad
you're such a brat pookie but we love
you yeah okay go ahead go okay so those
are just the people that like sent in
the letters now as it turned out
they actually had oh i forgot what
i can also do muscle shirts
but muscle shirts cost more
how much was the muscle shirt i don't
remember five or six bucks i think okay
we'll work out the price so let's just
say uh for a muscle shirt it's gonna be
25. okay go ahead
good
thank you all right
um yeah so
like i said he got like more than 70
responses of people who reportedly had
premonitions before it had happened like
i said we're just going on people say so
don't really know
but there was this one group uh it was i
think the initial group was like seven
people but it was mostly like these two
people that what was that oh she's in
the door oh she's trying to get in the
cabin
there's nothing in there either poke
she's trying to get she's like i'm just
trying to get inside things i don't care
um but there were really kind of like
two people who
seemed to come up with a lot of [ __ ] i
mean they came up with a lot of [ __ ]
that didn't come true but they came up
with a lot of [ __ ] that did come true
also
so one of these was a woman named
kathleen middleton
now
she not only had
dreams and visions and stuff like that
but she also uh allegedly had physical
symptoms too like when she was having a
premonition now she had mailed her
premonition about abervan to the evening
standard newspaper in response to
parker's ad on november 1st so like a
little more than a week after the
disaster had happened
now kathleen middleton was actually born
in the u.s she was actually born in
massachusetts but her parents were
british
now she was um a dancer when she was a
kid and she actually had a lot of
friends that went on to you know kind of
become famous in hollywood or whatever
but during the depression like her
parents uh kind of lost all their money
and they ended up having to move back to
london
uh middleton actually ended up opening a
school for dance and music which like in
the front room of her house so she would
like teach kids to dance and play the
piano and stuff like that
now she kind of had a history of
having premonitions and having these
kind of like i don't know psychic
phenomena i guess like happening around
her she kind of said when she was seven
that she remembered this one thing that
her mom was like in the kitchen frying
an egg
and uh the egg kind of like lifted
itself up and like rose out of the pan
and like touch the ceiling
um which
which she thought was apparently very
funny but her mom did absolutely not
think it was funny
and she actually went to a psychic or a
fortune teller or something like that
and the fortune teller told her uh
allegedly that an egg flying out of a
pan uh means someone's gonna die like
it's a death omen how the hell i never
heard that before how the hell does she
know this
i don't know
i don't know how does who know what
well maybe that's a thing i've never
heard it i've never heard of that [ __ ]
but i don't know i'm not real up on
death omens so other than the real you
know well-known ones okay so i don't
know maybe oh if the egg flies out of a
pan you're gonna die i've never heard of
that [ __ ] no i haven't either but like i
said it's absolutely you know there's a
lot of death omens it could it could
have been a thing i don't know now so
apparently that's what the fortune
teller said and apparently a couple
weeks later
one of the mom's
uh best friends
died
and was buried in her wedding dress
because she had just got married because
she was like really really young
so
middleton
said that she had premonitions most of
her life and would usually get like a
really bad headache um she said she
predicted earthquakes
she would get people's names and stuff
like that that would come to her she
never worked as a psychic or tried to
make money off it or anything like that
um she would she said when she had
visions or dreams or whatever so she
would sometimes draw it but a lot of
times she was just like it was just kind
of like in the way kind of thing and she
was always like trying to turn it off
because she was always kind of like
getting stuff happening and you know she
was busy and she didn't really have time
to like deal with it
but she did say in regards to abervan
she said that around four in the morning
on october 21st 1966 so only a few hours
before the cold tip collapsed um she was
52 at the time she said uh that she woke
up at four in the morning had a really
really really bad feeling okay
the camp guy says nice shirt i need an
extra large i think i got an extra large
in in um well i don't have my pen with
it okay go ahead right well no well get
me a pen it's like over there somewhere
and plus you stole one of my pens all
day i specifically told you not to steal
it i do what i wanted and you stole it
anyway okay go ahead and write some
stuff down he needs to extra large let
me go check
let me see if i have one
i'm gonna write it down here and i'm
gonna need like your address and so
don't put it in the chat but just you
know send me a message on facebook or
something like that and i'll like and
i'll
figure it out
um but yeah so let's see where was i
well i don't want to get too much into
it because then he'll come back and
talk
and i'll get all the i'll get all like
uh distracted
did you find anything
here to go in the next room they're all
in the closet in the gym over there
all right he's gonna take too long all
right so she wakes up at four in the
morning says she has a really really bad
feeling she says she woke up
and she was
she couldn't breathe and she was like
choking and she said she felt like the
walls were caving and like something was
like uh coming in on her okay that guy
got it extra large
shoot that out i'll send it to you okay
okay yeah like i said we got we even got
the um i got a scale and i got
a printer for the postage and [ __ ] like
that so we got all the stuff we can do
our uh we can do our own shipping right
from here now
oh look i got my little [ __ ]
radio is that going to make a bunch of
noise no no no i just needed it for a
flashlight that was on it okay
so anyway so yeah so she wakes up with
this horrible feeling feels like uh the
walls are closing in on her she said
uh and she actually told the guy who was
lodging it cam cabinet says he wants a
snake pliskin as well that's another
twenty dollars i uh i gotta get another
extra large that was the last extra
large okay
so um
if you want enough snake blisking you
gotta send me another 20.
okay
okay okay
can i go now yeah go ahead all right
so she tells her uh the guy that was
lodging in her house whose name was
alexander and he worked the night shift
so he got home like that morning and she
told about it she was like man i woke up
and i felt like really i think something
really bad's gonna happen
um
and so
apparently she had this feeling like the
night before it happened and then when
she saw it happen she and saw the ad
like she wrote to them
now in the weeks after the disaster uh
the psychiatrist barker he
had like uh he called the people
percipients that's what he called them
like the people that had um you know
that had premonitions about it and he
actually went out to meet a bunch of
them
now what he found from this uh kind of
a little bit unscientific i guess but
you just kind of like a field study i
guess so he goes out and like talks to
them
and he thought and somebody brought this
up earlier that he thought maybe that um
okay so there was another twenty-first
name okay let me ask you quick let me
ask you this camp guy do you want a big
image
or a small image of snake blisket here's
the difference
a small image
of the snake place can
will kind of make you look
uh
bigger
okay make it look more muscular the
bigger image is just kind of it'll wash
out a little bit be like this
so i have two different versions
a small image of snake play skin or a
full size it's up to you
just drop it in the comment section
we're gonna go ahead
okay where was i okay so um yeah so he
goes to meet a bunch of these people and
he figured out from talking to them that
probably these types of premonitions
were not
all that unusual
his kind of thing was uh this is from
the new yorker article
that he thought it might be as common as
left-handedness
and because he found this kind of
interesting he's like we need to broaden
this experiment experiment we need to
like kind of you know upscale this
somehow like make it bigger
now at the time the guy he'd been
working with at the evening standard
fairly uh you know he was also on tv
sometimes he was on the bbc and stuff
and uh him okay he wants a big image of
snake biscuit write that down
all right i got you
i mean i figured because that one looks
better yeah and that was my last extra
large so you have to wait a couple days
for me to get the second extra large
well i might have to go through there i
got to go through there and see like
what sizes we have so i might as well
order a bunch of them at once
there's only one extra large right now
so we at least need we need more that's
not what i said i said i need to go
through there and see what sizes are in
there
and then see if i need to order some
because i'm not going to order just one
shirt i'm going to order like a whole
bunch of different i mean might as well
i got you can't i got you camp guy i'll
take care of you i got your order
okay and then we'll get your address
later
how do we how do we normally get address
i usually with facebook or email or yeah
facebook is your address camp guy yeah
i'll send you like yeah
okay so where was i um
all right
so uh fairly like i said email
okay give me your email and i'll send
you my address well you take i can't
type it on here so you gotta type it
okay look just you type it you type it
type it on what on your thing you can
chat in the chat right yeah yeah yeah i
just can't
what's the email that we're using
just do gravecake okay
gmail.com
easy
okay
i sent it to us i put it in the comments
section grab cake at email.com gmail
gmail would come did you do it right
yeah i got it right i mean i haven't
seen this yeah yeah yeah that's it all
right yeah that's that's my i mean i
have several emails but that's what he
said he got it great okay okay got it
send me your ad senate sender or address
yeah
all right uh
yeah so anyway this guy that um you know
wrote for the paper he was also on tv
sometimes
so
one of the things
so him and barker and some of the people
that said that they had had premonitions
of the abravan disaster
they were
supposed to appear on uh david frost's
show which like i said if you're in the
uk i've even because i saw frost nixon
but
i even remember who david frost was so
and i'm from the us but i'm kind of like
an anglophile but yeah he had like a
really big like interview style like
chat show
back in the 1960s
and they were supposed to be on that
show
now
what ended up happening though
was that i guess
all of the people that were on the show
that had supposedly had premonitions
about the abervan disaster
um
fairly kind of looked in there like into
the green room like while they were all
waiting and was kind of like well
i'm paraphrasing but he says well i
don't really want to call him weirdos
but
i kind of feel like he was like
i don't call him weirdos they're kind of
weirdos
so yeah so there was that
now and it turned out that it was the
the show was like in two segments like
the first part of it had like some poet
laureate on there
and then the abervan people and barker
and them were supposed to be on the
second half
but i guess that david frost had also
looked into the green room and also
thought that these people that had the
premonitions were weirdos and decided
that he wasn't going to put them on the
show so he didn't even tell them he just
kind of like looked in the green room
was like nope not doing that and uh so
so they never like got the call to be
and he just carried on with the poet he
was talking to and didn't let them be on
the show uh and barker was like really
really mad as i guess she would be
because they came all the way there and
you know they didn't even get on the
show but i guess i don't know like frost
maybe thought oh this is my reputation
and i don't really want a bunch of like
wackos that have like these premonitions
i don't want them like sully in my show
i don't know whatever
but yeah so they didn't get on there
so uh so basically what they decided to
do after this well they're like okay
well [ __ ] it we're just gonna like
expand this out somehow
what we're gonna do because barker
thought that there was something maybe
that what he called like a pre-disaster
syndrome he didn't think everybody had
this but he thought that like some
people in the population
um that he called human seismographs
um would have some kind of like
premonitions whether they were mental
physical or both
um and he's like well we need to kind of
codify this we need to
set up
some kind of like infrastructure where
these people can report these bad
feelings that they have in it
you know so that we can maybe kind of
like see patterns and maybe we can
prevent like some of these disasters
from happening they're essentially he
was essentially doing like minority
report i guess but like not so much
about crime but more about like
disasters mostly natural disasters but
like human disasters too like plane
crashes and [ __ ] like that okay we got
another one
okay i'd love one of those cannon shirts
too extra large for me as well okay
okay next so we gotta order a couple
more largest
okay
i thought i was going to be the only one
in my area with one but it looks like
camp guy is it has one also okay oh it's
a small world after um
yeah i'll send you one excellent cannon
yeah it's going to take me take us a
couple days to get the shirts i mean
jiffy shirts is pretty quick if i order
them tomorrow then i'll probably get
them the day after the day after and
then i'll shoot them out and they'll
send them out to you yeah um uh send us
your address at gravecake.com
or what is it gravecake what at gmail at
gmail and um
i'll send it to you
if you have any problems just contact us
on any platform of 13 o'clock and
give us your address and we'll we'll
ship it out we have the ability to ship
and weigh right from here now so
we can [ __ ] uh
they'll pick it up we can box it up here
and they'll pick it up soon as we tell
them to
so we're good to go
yeah i don't have to go to the post
we're gonna have to go to the post
office we are a post office now
so we're good to go
and if y'all want any shirts i got
[ __ ]
cannon
i got
snake pliskin i got so many of them i
mean we still got all the old ones yeah
i got all the old ones i have [ __ ]
wayland industries i have
[ __ ] um um
uh replicant t-shirts from wait uh from
what was in oh [ __ ] man i gotta get that
one man i'm sitting here i need to
[ __ ] have my shirts at hand so i can
show everything that we're selling
but uh go ahead go ahead and go
yeah go ahead and go
well gee thank you man
[Laughter]
since it's like the topic that we're
supposed to be talking about
but uh yeah
so uh okay so like i said they wanted to
expand this out because they're kind of
like well if we have enough hits come in
and it's specific enough that we can act
on it then maybe we can like prevent
something like abervan from happening
again so we need to like expand the
program
so barker and fairly the guy from the
evening standard um they got this guy
named charles wintour who was the editor
of the evening standard at the time
um they're like we want to start like
essentially like a bureau premonitions
bureau
and they're like we'll just do kind of
like a pie this is like a pilot program
at the time
they're like for a year like you know
from when we launch it
everybody want everybody to send in if
they have any dreams or visions or
anything like that that seem
precognitive that seem like it's
foretelling disaster of some kind uh
please send those in
and then we will compare them to events
and we'll see how um okay let me guys
show you what i have
corralco studios
okay
i can do that also it's a fantastic
[ __ ]
design it's just it's exactly like what
they showed oh [ __ ] i can't get it close
enough
you guys know that studio it's great all
right a bunch of b movies i have that
these are original designs nobody else
[ __ ] offers this
tyrell
genetic replicants i have that also
twenty dollars
and i'll send you one
okay
and the other one i have
this is the pliskin shirt that they're
talking about large plate skin
image
that's based on the [ __ ] ford cobra
image
you'll never get it anywhere else
exclusive
that [ __ ] is bootleg all right that is a
[ __ ] copyright violation but we're
selling this [ __ ] cause they're handmade
all right
and that's that snake pliskin right
there that snake pliskin vibe
that [ __ ] is badass
you can get it in just a regular t-shirt
of whatever size you want or a muscle
shirt
twenty dollar super chat and i'll send
you to send it to you
okay
okay yeah jeffy art said maybe you guys
should do a separate stream showcasing
your designs yeah we probably should
yeah
yes but here's the thing man
we have to [ __ ] do
uh commercials of some sort
okay
all right uh i lost my place okay
so yeah
so they tell people for a year we're
gonna do this like i said pilot program
for this bureau
so if you have any feelings or anything
like that that seems prophetic like
dreams visions please send them in um
you know if it's some kind of disaster
something that we can like uh you know
compare to an actual event
so they wanted to do that so they even
had like um
fairly had like a stamp made with you
know date on it so that you could when
[ __ ] would come in they would stamp it
so then they compare it to stuff later
on to see how accurate it was and [ __ ]
like that so they started this little
bureau this little experiment
they started it uh early january of
1967.
now fairly from the evening standard
like the science correspondent he came
up with uh an 11 point scoring system
so you'd send in a prediction
and he's like okay we'll give five
points for how unusual it is i guess i'm
not really entirely sure what that means
i guess like
rarity or you know detail attention
detail maybe something like that uh five
points for how accurate it is and i'm
assuming that that was uh after the
event had actually happened um you know
like i said at this point they weren't
really trying to prevent stuff this was
just kind of like the pilot program
where they were seeing if there was some
kind of
phenomena there that they could work off
of so they wanted to kind of see
are we gonna have like this big influx
of people that are like sending in these
accurate predictions that we can like
match to stuff later on and then we can
like work from there so five points for
unusualness five points for accuracy one
point for timing which i guess would
have to like time frame like how soon
before the event or whatever you know is
there enough time to like act on it
now when they launched it um
interestingly that same day
there was a guy named donald campbell
who was uh 46 years old at the time and
he uh was like a boat racer like he and
he would do um he was trying to do like
world records like world speed records
like in a speedboat
now uh
on the particular day that they launched
this program funnily enough um he was
going about 300 miles an hour on this
boat like trying to uh trying to break a
record
and he uh the boat flipped and killed
him
now interestingly
he had been very superstitious they said
he was afraid of uh the color green
and he also played solitaire now the day
before he died
he had on his solitaire game he turned
over the ace of spades and the queen
and then all the reporters that were
there because he was talking to them
about um you know the the
record he was gonna break he says you
know mary queen of scots drew the same
cards before her execution in 1587.
um and then he said and this is a quote
i know that one of my family is going to
get the chop i pray to god it is not me
turns out guess what it was him he did
die like the day after that so you know
that was kind of interesting also that
that happened like on that day that he
seemed to have had a premonition of his
own death although like i said he raced
speed boats which is a very risky
proposition so i don't think it's crazy
to maybe like have a bad feeling that oh
man i'm not gonna like come out of this
one i don't know i kind of feel like
maybe
now uh the premonitions bureau even
though it sounds like kind of a crazy
idea i mean it's not that crazy if you
really think about it but it wasn't the
first time that something like this had
been i don't know if like attempted
would be the word but like people had
ideas about it like in the 1920s there
was a guy who was named jw dunn who was
a aeronautical engineer
and he wrote a book called an experiment
with time
and he was trying to tie in his
dreams like that he thought were
precognitive and he was kind of talking
about how it related to like quantum
physics relativity stuff like that um a
lot of people didn't really understand
it
but he um was one of the one of the
first people i think that was telling
people like keep track of their dreams
like as soon as you wake up write your
dreams down because a lot of them might
be prophetic um and we don't know
because most people when you wake up
like you forget your dream so you should
probably like write them down as soon as
you wake up and then you can keep track
of like how if any of them like come
true or not
there was also something like a few
years before like in 1963 uh jb priestly
who was a playwright um he actually kind
of had a same kind of thing where he
asked viewers to like send in their kind
of if you had precognition or anything
like that and he got like 1500 replies
so it wasn't the first time i think that
barker though was like trying to
actually like codify this like make this
a thing i think he envisioned
like a database
essentially of people
every time they had like a bad feeling
or a vision or a prophetic dream or
something like that they would write it
down and they would send it in and i
kind of feel like he was feeling like
there'd be this like everybody would it
would all be catalogued and when the
technology was available they would keep
track of it so they could track patterns
and stuff like that and i think that he
wanted to get to a point where they
would be able to
you know narrow the focus enough that
they could maybe prevent some of the
stuff from happening that people had
that had predicted you know what i'm
saying i think that was what he was
hoping would happen that i mean spoiler
alert that's not what happened but i
think that's what he was envisioning
that's kind of the feeling i get
um
yeah i mean he's basically like yeah
that's kind of what he wanted to do we
need to like prevent disasters
and
he wanted this to be like a big what he
called like a repository for
you know
dreams and visions and things like that
an early warning system that's what he
called it
so uh
he's like
we're gonna do this for a year and if it
works out like if we see any patterns or
stuff like that then we'll
go to parliament we'll go to like higher
up authorities and see if we can get
some kind of like funding and like
expand this because like i said really
it was just like three dudes i mean it
was like it was him he was a
psychiatrist and then you had
you know the science correspondent from
the eating standard and the editor of
the evening standard that was kind of
the whole bureau at this point because
like i said it was very
they were just trying to like see if it
would work
now he did know
at the beginning that they would
probably be this is a quote from him
there might be numerous false alarms
particularly in the early stages when
the operators were inexperienced
and he also uh kind of got into at least
they kind of knew about this but he was
kind of talking about
because this is something maybe we
brought this up on the nostradamus show
or like some other stuff about
premonitions
so if you have a premonition that some
bad shit's gonna happen like i like for
example let's say i had a premonition
that it's like oh if i leave the house
today a meteor's gonna follow me okay so
i don't leave the house that data meteor
doesn't fall on me does that mean the
meteor was gonna fall on me did i avert
it
like then
the premonition is not a premonition
anymore because it didn't happen
and because it didn't happen like you
don't know if it would have happened had
you not had the premonition so it's like
a paradox
so he was kind of like talking about
that a little bit too like because he's
like you know what if for example like
all these people had had like a bad
feeling oh my god the coal tip is gonna
like slide down an abravan and so they
told us no kids go to school that day or
anything like that and nobody died that
it's like
you know what i mean it's just kind of
like well then it didn't happen exactly
the way people's premonitions went to
and i kind of feel like this even that
kind of like paradox goes back to the
[ __ ] biblical times probably probably
like before
that's the whole problem with like
premonitions right if you have a
premonition and like then it doesn't
happen then it's not really a
premonition anymore isn't it because it
didn't happen
it'll happen eventually
if you wait around long enough
tammy says i feel like i'm going to melt
anytime i step outside yeah same
uh jason s says i have coincidences like
i watched the movie goodfellas the day
before ray leota died yeah i've had
things like that happen
i just kind of feel like
i don't know it's just probably i feel
like maybe
i'm not i'm not saying that some people
don't have some like here's here's the
weird thing
i dreamt that somebody was
took uh an aircraft
it was a
like an airliner
and flew it
and dove it down into a damn
express building and blew it up
the next day i woke up and 9 11 happened
a lot of people said that they had
previously yeah it was some weird [ __ ]
but a lot of them were kind of vague
though like well just kind of like the
abervan ones it's just kind of like oh i
had a dream that there was a welsh minor
and that everything was black you know
yeah no i had i had the ability i had
the dream somebody's flew a [ __ ]
plane into the federal express building
it's like a warehouse
on the ground it didn't have anything to
do with with [ __ ]
uh you know what i mean the twin towers
but that that was weird that was weird
woke up
and then a few hours later i saw those
planes hit those buildings on 9 11. it
was weird
i mean kind of like doing the research
for the show actually did sort of like
make me want to write my start writing
my dreams down like i do remember some
of them but most of my dreams are really
boring you know what i mean i kind of
feel like most people's dreams are
really boring it's just like regular
[ __ ]
so
but maybe i'm having like really
exciting ones that i don't really
remember like once yeah
you'll have good dreams you'll forget
them by the time you wake up that's what
i'm saying yeah so it's just kind of
like
i don't know i just feel like most minor
boring which which is crazy because i i
feel like i used to have more
they weren't prophetic obviously because
it was [ __ ] that could never happen
um because my dreams are like weird as
[ __ ] but
some of them like i actually like turned
into stories
like the really bizarre ones but i feel
like i haven't had really bizarre ones
in a really long time like most of them
are just like boring ass [ __ ] yeah
i don't know why okay so we got
next dimension wanting a [ __ ] shirt
camp guy wanting a shirt does anybody
else want a shirt
megan got
snake pliskin
i got i got a bunch of them okay
i don't know what i'm talking about i
got snake pliskin i got uh [ __ ] uh
genetic replicants from uh and i got
let's see what i got
it's always better to show than to just
see
i thought you just did that like five
seconds no i'm still i'm still [ __ ]
selling snake biscuit
snake meliskin stink blisskin
[ __ ] how drunk are you
all right more human than human genetic
replicas
okay
and i got
carol co studios
and i got canon studios
the [ __ ] kings of b movies
to drop a super chat 20 super chat and
i'll sell you one
cannon also did invaders for mars the
toby hooper movie which we just talked
about the other day yeah and they also
did life force also which is also an
awesome canon did did a lot of cool [ __ ]
cannon did superman four
one of the best supermans that wasn't
cool though that was terrible and one of
the best
better than superman three
yeah
the problem with [ __ ] superman 4 was
[ __ ] quest for quest for peace i
think it was called the problem with
that was the [ __ ] opening
was the opening of
credits
it didn't look that
good but it it could that could have
been a great movie i could fix that
movie if i had the money i could fix
that movie but nobody would care
okay so once they had established this
bureau as kind of small as it was
now they ended up getting uh a few kind
of
tantalizing
hits this is kind of interesting
remember i said that like they they
would get like a lot of
people writing stuff in but most of the
stuff uh did never come to anything
right
but they had two particular people um
you know the woman i mentioned earlier
and this guy named alan hencher
and
several of their predictions came true
so there was that
so spring of 1967 alan henscher
who had also seen uh abervan before it
happened reportedly
he called barker up and he said there's
going to be a plane crash over the
mountains
um and i think that 123 or 124 people
are going to be killed
so uh barker logged this uh blog this
call which happened on march 21st at six
in the morning
thirty days later uh a britannia
passenger aircraft carrying 130 people
attempted to land in cyprus during bad
weather
and uh crashed into a hill breaking into
pieces 124 people
died in the crash
um
and a couple more died later but 124
died in the crash so he said 120 324
that's what he said so not bad camp guys
going the carrollco and the tyrell also
are awesome also you can get me next
week bro next week or next month go
ahead and hit us up i'll send them to
you you can have a whole collection and
then i'll pull out more of them
then go ahead
there are good shirts there is i [ __ ]
love those old studios
but yeah so um i mean he didn't have any
super like
all he came up with was plane crash
mountains and he came up with about the
right number of victims which is pretty
good
but
you wouldn't be able like i said and i
think barker knew that there wasn't any
really any actionable information
because it's like you know there's
zillions of like
you know planes every day and you don't
know like when it's gonna happen i mean
this actually ended up happening 30 days
later so it absolutely could have been a
coincidence
but um
this guy hencher he actually again had
just like the lady we were talking about
earlier had a history of
having uh premonitions like from a young
age although not from when he was a kid
he was actually in a car accident in his
mid-20s
and he said after that he started having
premonitions which also came with
physical symptoms um headaches
uh just feeling like he said he felt
like a band of steel was around his head
and that's how he knew that um the
visions or the feelings that he was
having like related to something that
was gonna happen
now apparently
even though he had given this alleged
prediction like 30 days before it
actually happened on the day that it
happened he actually did call barker
like a bunch of times or um i think
actually fairly was trying to call him
but couldn't get like hold of him
um
interestingly though on the same day
that the crash happened or like that
later that night
um hencher called
john barker at one in the morning
and he was like freaking out
when barker answered the phone he's like
bro what the [ __ ] why are you calling me
at one in the morning so i'm i'm
imagining that's probably what he said
because that's what i would have said
um he says
check your gas supply i was i've been
worried about you all day he said
now at this point uh john barker lived
with his wife and they had uh three kids
and i think that um his wife was also
pregnant like with their first fourth
kid they had a big uh house they were
renting in a village called yakulton
which i'm not entirely sure where that
is
now there actually was no gas supply to
the house
but evidently hencher had been having
like a really bad feeling that something
really really bad was going to happen to
barker himself like the psychiatrist
that started this whole thing and he's
like i've just been having this bad
feeling i think something's gonna happen
i don't know if it's the gas it's but he
felt like it was an accident so that's
he's like i don't know what it is but
it's something really bad
so after he said look the house doesn't
have a gas supply
um so then henshir said do you have a
dark colored car
and barker said yeah it's dark green
and henshire says be very careful look
after yourself
and barker's like well is my life in
danger and hencher said yes i very very
strongly feel that your life is in
danger and that you're going to die in
an accident i'm not sure when but it's
going to be very soon
so barker said that he couldn't get any
more information now he actually like
after the day after this phone call he
wrote this big long
memo about it now the memo along with a
bunch of letters from his uh was
actually unearthed by the author who i
was talking about earlier sam knight who
wrote a book about this case
which just came out like a year or two
ago
and um he found it in the society
perceptual research
archive
which is in the cambridge university
library
and barker actually gave a pretty
detailed history of hencher and his
premonitions about albervan his
premonitions about the plane crash
um
and he called this particular memo
some interesting predictions and a
possible death sentence which seems very
glib for somebody
who's who like a psychic is called and
said dude i think you're gonna die
uh and this is a quote this is what he
said in the memo
it would be wrong for me to say that i
was not frightened by a prediction of
this nature i mean he's just like so
he's so like
casual about it i love it
i intend keeping a diary from now on to
record my reactions to this on a daily
basis i suppose anybody who plays about
with precognition in this way to some
extent sticks his necks out neck out and
must accept what he gets the important
thing though is for this information to
be recorded so that if anything does
happen it should cause some interest and
may stimulate others to continue in this
important work so he's basically saying
hey if i die and this prediction comes
true
then
that's good i have a record of it and
people can like look into it further
like after i'm gone
so
yeah that would be crazy
and he says having recently written a
book on people who were scared to death
i'm perhaps beginning to feel what this
would feel like
i mean you know or what it would be like
so um
basically it's just like like i don't
know that's just like very very funny to
me i mean like i said he's
he was a a very scientific minded person
like i said he was really into the
paranormal but he did really seem to
like approach it
from a point of view of like not really
being all that scared of it i mean he
really did want to buy like he at one
point he wanted to buy like this haunted
pub um you know just so he could study
it like so he could live there and study
it um but he didn't think his wife and
kids would be too into it so he never
did it but the fact that this psychic
who had apparently predicted abervan and
also predicted this plane crash pretty
accurately
thanks um
would call him and say bro i think
you're gonna die like you really need to
watch yourself and that that he's so
he just seems like so like laissez-faire
about it like i don't know that's like
very very funny to me
so um what they were talking about fair
we're talking about fairly later and
this is kind of going back to something
like you always say about rspk is that
fairly later said um
i don't know he was basically like i
don't know if the idea of this bureau
is all that great because if you get
people thinking about
having premonitions or trying to predict
the future then it's not going to work
it's going to hamstring it because it
works better if you're not thinking
about it because it always seems to
happen accidentally so like i said by
implication that kind of means that even
if you had a bureau like this it might
be kind of useless because
you know people just get like these
random feelings and yeah maybe some of
them come true later on but you don't
know which ones are going to come true
you don't know exactly you don't have
enough details to like prevent the [ __ ]
from happening so it's just kind of like
like i said i don't know if there's like
enough actionable information because it
just seems so
random and so vague you know what i mean
so it's just that kind of thing
now um because hencher had uh
you know told barker that he was gonna
die
um
middleton the other woman that was uh
that was kind of their star predictor or
whatever
um she had made some predictions that
didn't come true now she did make some
that did come true too she made a bunch
but
um most of them like i said they got a
lot of predictions and
you know 95 i don't know the exact
percentage but most of them did not come
true the ones that did come true were
pretty impressive but like i said
because it was such a small percentage
could be a coincidence or there could be
some other [ __ ] going on too
um one thing that middleton did predict
sort of correctly
happened in spring of 1967
she said that she'd had a vision of a
space man
uh who was uh terrified and he was like
floating in space and he was like
freaking out um and
she had that the night before a soviet
cosmonaut named vladimir komarov
died during re-entry like on his way
back to earth so people like counted
that as a hit like i said it's kind of
vague like what she said but you know
there was something the next day that
matched up to it
now may 1st um this was 10 days after
hensher had first called barker and said
hey i think you're going to die i'm
worried about you
he said i think there's going to be
another uh plane crash another air
disaster of some kind that is taking
place within uh three weeks and he
described the plane he said it's going
to have this weird tail fans and there's
be kids on the plane or anything like
that
so um but he didn't have enough again he
did there wasn't enough information to
like have prevented it
so uh
so now we're kind of talking about
because
hencher had called barker and basically
given him what he called a death
sentence he's like i think you're gonna
die um i foresee an accident
and
this is exactly the kind of stuff that
barker was interested in there's the
kind of stuff that you wrote his book
about you know if some but if you
genuinely believe that somebody like a
fortune teller or you know you had a
voodoo curse put on you or something
like that where somebody said that you
were gonna die
does that make a self-fulfilling
prophecy in some people like if you
don't actually don't believe it then it
probably doesn't happen but is
there some kind of effect some kind of
biological thing that happens that will
actually kill you because you believe it
so strongly that so that's kind of like
his area of expertise now as i mentioned
earlier there is everybody knows about
the placebo effect right it's like
they're like oh here's this amazing drug
that will make you feel like superman um
and then they give you a sugar pill and
then you know a large percentage of
people will actually feel like superman
even though it's not [ __ ] all in it
well well yeah it's a placebo it works
okay it doesn't work on everybody but um
it works
enough that it's a thing yeah but let me
tell you all something
yeah there are some people you can say
you feel like superman take this pill
and the police sibo effect the only
thing i've ever taken
that actually makes you feel like
superman would be anavar pills which is
an anabolic steroid
that will make you feel like superman
there's a difference
good
but you've never like been given
something that didn't have [ __ ] all in
it no that you didn't know about
no i mean the whole we'll see the whole
thing is the belief is what makes it
work that's why it's a placebo effect
yeah the difference is is that on anavar
you can go and lift a bunch of weight
and you'll lift more well maybe you
still could if you really believed it
was that but didn't have anything in it
because look at okay now there are some
documented cases for example we just saw
something about this the other day
about you know there's all those cases
about
uh you know moms or parents or some
people like that and their kid is like
trapped under a car and they lift a
[ __ ] car and obviously these are not
weight lifters they wouldn't be able to
lift that otherwise but
they were just kind of like they didn't
even think about oh i can't lift that
car they're just like i have to save my
kid and they didn't even think about it
and they just lifted the [ __ ] car so
i kind of adrenaline though so well but
i kind of feel like it might be related
i'm just saying that the whole placebo
effect is predicated on you believing
that this pill will make you feel a
certain way or will cure a certain
disease or whatever it doesn't always
work like i said but you have to believe
that it does you have to believe that
there's something in it even if there's
technically nothing in it well um with
anavar
not only not only you lift more weight
you feel a certain way and there's a
bunch of side effects like muscle cramps
which that doesn't happen just by
psychosomatics
so
i would be able to tell the difference
pretty sure that's what everybody says
yeah i'd be able to because there's a
bunch of negative side effects that come
from nfr
not a bunch of negative but like i said
the whole point is that if somebody gave
you
that
um
it wasn't anything there was nothing in
it it was just sugar pill but they told
you it was that the placebo effect says
that a certain percentage of people will
react the exact same way as if there had
been something in there but because they
believed something was in there yeah
that doesn't mean that anavar isn't real
you give that's not what i said that's a
completely different argument you give a
bunch of anavar to a female her [ __ ]
gets big and she starts growing a beard
you know
that that that that was a real [ __ ]
phenomenon
you know what i mean because that does
happen
not a testosterone even more so
you give a hundred milligram of
testosterone to a woman it's not placebo
she grows a [ __ ] beard
she becomes a man 18 months later and
there's [ __ ] video evidence of it
so yeah there is a placebo effect but
there's also a real effect
well yeah like i said those are two
different arguments that's not what
they're saying okay they're not saying
that oh drugs are [ __ ] and they
don't remember obviously okay what
they're saying is that some in some
people in a significant percentage of
people yeah the belief that something is
gonna work is enough i guess we'll make
it work the same way that it would work
even if there was something in it even
if there's nothing in it that's what the
placebo effect is okay it's not saying
that like the drug doesn't really do
anything don't work right that's not
what it's saying that's two completely
different things they're just saying
that if you believe
that that's what the drug is right
then it will in a certain percentage
it will work the same
let me sort this out for the audience
i'm just talking to a girl that we know
from the club
she thought steroids and hormones
didn't really work
and then i showed her a video of a girl
who was transitioning
from female to male
using testosterone and in 18 months she
was a she was a man
you know she went from a pretty girl to
a man and then she was like oh i had no
idea that that actually worked
[ __ ] it yeah it does there's a placebo
effect but there is also a real effect
and there are
some hormones and
hormones and drugs
many of them actually work
that that that's the difference
some some of it's just mind trick
other stuff is no it's real it's real
yeah you can take a girl and turn her
into a man
with a beard and everything okay the
same [ __ ] [ __ ] up attitude i don't
know why some [ __ ] pretty girl would
ever want to be a man it's a hard road
to walk but they do it
they do it you know hopefully
and then they go out and get in a fight
with some other dude and he beats her to
death you know what i mean because
it's [ __ ] terrible don't do it don't
do it caitlyn higgins said do you think
it's possible that these so-called
premonitions are just instances of
people not experiencing time in a linear
fashion if the mind also works on a
quantum level i mean that could be a
possibility
that i'm not i don't know i'm not
entirely convinced
that
people are like look i've had some i've
heard some weird stories i'm not saying
that
but
i'm kind of like i'm a very very
skeptical person and i kind of err on
the side of
law of large numbers kind of thing it's
like look um you know when something
terrible happens like 911 or abervan or
something like that you know there's
going to be a certain probably small
percentage of people that
just happen by coincidence to have a
weird dream beforehand and they just
remember it because it related to
something that happened like shortly
afterward
so
i'm not like i don't know like the
effect isn't big enough for me to say
yeah that's a real thing that exists
but
if it does exist
it could be
i mean because time is not we experience
it as linear obviously because that's
the way our brains evolved
but time is not really linear not
exactly the way we perceive it so it's
possible that there's some
part of our brain and maybe some people
more than others who maybe kind of
experience stuff more like it actually
is and so
it could be that they're seeing some
[ __ ] that happened in the future or some
[ __ ] that happened in the past um but
they don't really know like what to make
of it so it could be that it could be
that i don't think like it's
supernatural to that
extent i think that it's like a natural
phenomenon that we probably don't
understand yet if there's anything to
explain because i think a lot of it can
be explained by coincidence
um because it's very easy
after the fact especially if it's a real
big disaster
it's very easy after the fact to be like
oh yeah i totally had a dream
you know last night a week ago something
like that and
that vaguely resembled that because you
probably have dreams all the time that
you don't remember
but just because you happen to have a
dream you know a couple days ago oh i
dreamed about a plane crash and then the
next day or a couple days later oh a
plane crash so you're gonna remember
that and you're gonna think oh my god i
predicted that [ __ ] so i think a lot of
it is probably that but i don't know you
know i'm just saying i'm not convinced
i'm not convinced but anyway what i was
saying when you went off on the whole
thing about placebo effect yeah the
thing about the placebo effect which is
it largely i don't know if i'd maybe
it's neutral but i guess it's more of a
positive thing because like you don't
even some people you don't have to give
them the actual drug you can just tell
them it's the actual drug and it'll have
like mostly the same effect as the
actual drug if you gave it to them but
there's also a negative like a dark side
to that which is called the nocebo
effect which is kind of like the placebo
effect but
bad but like negative
for example um
this was kind of like first used in 1961
that's when the term was coined
and it's kind of like
okay so for example there was a in 2003
there was a trial of uh beta blockers
now they had two
uh groups
of men
now one group of patients
uh was told that the drug that we're
going to give you these beta blockers
will cause erectile dysfunction
the other group was not told that now
guess what happened
after three months 32 percent of those
in the first group complained of
erectile problems compared with three
percent in the second
this pill did not cause erectile
dysfunction but the people's belief that
it did it did right made it happen right
so like i said this is like the dark
side of the placebo effect negative [ __ ]
happens too and they think that maybe
this is what's behind
you know quote-unquote like voodoo
deaths like people that
you know if they actually believe in
fortune tellers or voodoo curses or
something like that and somebody says
[ __ ] you're going to die on this date
of this it makes it happen like
obviously it doesn't happen to everybody
but if they really believe it then it
does hey
all [ __ ] you know i mean i've fessed
up to this many times before i'm on a
bunch of [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] 53 years old i'm on a bunch
of [ __ ] that i've heard that what can
affect that and just worrying about it
can cause me to [ __ ]
have erectile problems
you know me and jenna be throwing down
and i'm like maybe i'm on some [ __ ]
right now that might [ __ ] prevent me
from doing it just thinking about it
well yes and erectile dysfunction i
think in particular is something that i
mean not always because it actually does
have physical physical uh most of the
[ __ ] things but a lot of it is mental a
lot of that's just mental because um
[ __ ] when i was [ __ ] 20 years old
thinking about it too much could [ __ ]
stop it all right [ __ ] um
worrying about certain things could
cause performance problems
the best thing to do is to be totally
[ __ ] uh blissfully unaware and just
[ __ ] up
[ __ ] up drunk and not caring and just
being very aggressive and a dude will
[ __ ] follow through
but this is like
dudes will get [ __ ] tied up in the
[ __ ] and start thinking there's some
kind of physical problem when there's
not physical
it's because you're thinking about it
can [ __ ] stop well some i mean
and i'm not saying look i'm a classic
overthinker but um in in a lot of ways
that's good because if i wasn't an
overthinker then i would then i wouldn't
be able to like do all the [ __ ] that i
do because i have to keep track of what
you think but there are some things that
you shouldn't overthink because you'll
end up like shooting yourself in the
dick metaphorically right yeah
um so i try not to do that like on some
particular things but it is absolutely a
thing um it's better to be dumb than to
be smart [ __ ] just don't worry i
would well i want that [ __ ] honestly
though i've heard that but i wouldn't i
don't think i'd like to be dumb well you
know what i mean i mean i don't mean
dumb dumb i mean yeah but don't be aware
of things just follow your instincts and
your gut i mean it's weird it's weird
because
people that
overthink things because i overthink
things yeah but i wouldn't i don't like
it but i wouldn't want to be different
yeah because if i was different i don't
think that i'd be able to do all the
stuff that i do because the only i mean
it stresses me out but i still i don't
know like it's a weird yeah it's a weird
thing to like destroy describe to
somebody that doesn't do it you gotta
what's funny is that
when you start to get older you'll fall
into a lot of the [ __ ] stereotypes
that you believed when you were younger
too is another thing don't [ __ ] think
about things just do
the the conscious mind is good
in a lot of ways especially with problem
solving but it's like a two-edged sword
the conscious mind can also undermine
you
well it can be an obstacle depending
yeah depending on what it is that you're
talking about the animal mind is a lot
better it's a lot more fun okay that
that's how i one thing i have found in
my
creative life i guess is that when i'm
writing stories
it's better to just turn the brain off
about it yeah don't think about it
and for that reason i think my [ __ ]
comes out better if i write by hand
rather than typing yeah because a lot of
times like i'll have a notebook and if i
just write by hand i don't have to look
at my hand yeah and i'm not so i'm like
i'm just not going to think about it i'm
just going to write without thinking
it's almost like automatic writing but
not like that woo-woo
star wars terms it's the
she's talking about and i'm talking
about the same thing talking about the
series where they're in the we're
talking about
the scene where they're in the
millennium falcon and obi-wan puts the
[ __ ] blinders on luke and says your
eyes can deceive you [ __ ] don't worry
just go by your feelings and [ __ ] and
then he beats the remote
just let the [ __ ] happen don't think
about it i mean like i said depending on
what it is depends on what it is
depending on what it is i don't advocate
just like going with your gut on
everything because i don't think that's
a good idea there's a certain times for
it but yeah i mean it's good to have
like a balance of those two things
though and like i said i would not trade
in yes i overthink yes it makes me
anxious yes it makes me stressed out
right but
i would rather have that than not have
that right you know what i'm saying yeah
i understand but um
yeah so
so that's the thing so yeah so they told
the guys that this drug would cause
erectile dysfunction and it absolutely
did which like i said doesn't surprise
me because erectile dysfunction not
always because sometimes like i said
there are physical uh things that are
going on
but a lot of erectile dysfunction is
psychological i think almost all of it
um so
unless you're very old and have very uh
bad health
i think most of it's psychological
yeah well i mean a lot of well yeah and
a lot of like well a lot of sexual stuff
is performance anxiety yeah
like i said unless you have physical
problems unless you have physical
problems because some people do yeah
like if you ever belonged in a company
or [ __ ] they go in the military
to where they want you to do your
analysis okay
if you got a dude even if you know him
he's standing right next to you and he
wants you to piss into a [ __ ] cup all
right he's like come on ross let the
[ __ ] go you can't [ __ ] relax enough
to piss in the damn cup it takes hours
well [ __ ] man i don't even know if it's
your buddy telling you to piss in the
cup well i don't even like going to the
bathroom like in a public bathroom if
there's somebody in the next stall over
you're right yeah so it's like i can
imagine for dudes it must be worse
because you're like at a urinal where
everybody can see you but like even the
women's room where you have a stall it's
like i don't even like to pee if there's
a girl next to me in this doll like
carol was kind of like waiting i had to
take a military-style urinal so i got my
[ __ ] wazir out and [ __ ] there was
dude my wife's here i'm gonna say it's
like that's like the arabic versus here
[ __ ] this and i'm sitting there
trying to piss in the damn cup and my
[ __ ] boys looking right at my dick
come on ross go ahead and let the [ __ ]
out man come on we got to make sure
you're not honest with you so hold on
let me come on man well it's like who is
like relax right
if it's another dude he should know not
to look at your dick yeah he's like i'm
just making sure that's a party
i'm making sure you don't have a bladder
in there trying to [ __ ]
squeeze it out from a [ __ ] straw and
[ __ ] see you can like subvert them yeah
and i was trying to [ __ ] with him i was
like you're not looking at it too hard
like it's not lust right he's like no
so we start [ __ ] with each other and
that's just that's why you keep looking
and then yeah so why are you looking at
it so hard i'm trying to piss and he's
like man just go ahead let the [ __ ] out
bro i gotta go i mean i'd have to be
really really drunk before i'd have to
pee into somebody else i've been there
that's what i'm saying
i mean i think i've been drunk enough
yeah i was just kind of like [ __ ] i'm
just yeah and it's your friend but right
it's still [ __ ] hard to [ __ ]
piss when somebody's looking at you yeah
even if you know that person yeah yeah
yeah he's like your friend you know you
just yeah like i said i said i've had
friends that were close enough that it's
like you know you're getting ready in
the bathroom and it's like oh i gotta
pee and they're putting makeup on or
something like that and you it's fine
but it's like it's still a little bit
weird right yeah it's still a little bit
weird yeah it's a little bit weird yeah
but uh so i can see that y'all know what
i'm talking about i can see that well i
might do something hey soph what's up
sneaking in to say hi wondering what the
heck this sidetrack is oh i mean it's
not that much of a sidetrack because we
were talking about it in my defense
because we were talking about the nocebo
effect yeah right which has something to
do with
uh people that have premonitions of like
when they're gonna die and like it
actually makes them die and that's kind
of like what the psychiatrist behind
this uh premonition thing was like
studying so we were talking about
studies where
uh you know they gave people drugs that
said hey this is going to cause erectile
dysfunction and it did like in 30 like
not in everybody but like a significant
percentage yeah and i was talking about
being in the military doing your
analysis we're trying to piss the cup
and it's your buddy even [ __ ] holding
the cup and you still can't just [ __ ]
and he's sitting there talking to you
come on go listen and you're fighting
over taking a piss you know what i mean
but uh so now if you for you people new
to the show soph has been over and
visited us many times she's a good
friend of ours beautiful
blonde
honky ice princess of the north up in
mississippi yeah that's what i call her
she loves
the vice princess of the [ __ ] north
of michigan and um
her and i grew up around the same people
and she's friends with the little sister
or one of my best friends up in michigan
so
uh
cool cool gotcha
okay i'll show a picture i'll show a
picture
wait does she say that's okay or no yeah
she don't care she's been on the show
before she's been on the show before
sophie said i haven't put on an actual
video version of this in forever just
the audio the office is looking super
cool jenny oh thank you yeah it will be
right yeah wow i can't believe that you
haven't seen it like since we've had
because how long has that been like six
or seven months i think we moved here
last september or october yeah that's
self yeah
i'm saying what are you doing dude
trying to get it yeah that's soph right
there yeah she's visited us
and you need to come down and visit
again so if it's about time for you
to come up and visit us i'll [ __ ] set
you up in a little room here we'll get
you a little uh
sleeping [ __ ] type car because i
don't have a guest bed
all right we gotta get one actually yeah
we gotta get one but we've been out to
the club together and she's been on the
show what i don't remember it was a long
time ago about two years ago she was on
one of our shows yeah and then she got
[ __ ] self-conscious and then she had
to walk off
and then she didn't she didn't complete
the show i'm still self-conscious about
the show too but i've kind of gotten
used to it the alcohol helps yeah yeah
i still get well i'm not as
self-conscious like once the show starts
yeah i'm fine
but um leading up to the show like the
half hour before i get stressed out
still i get like weird like stage fright
which is stupid because i've been doing
this forever but you know what i mean
yeah it's [ __ ] weird
that's how my [ __ ] goes we'd love to
have you back stuff whenever you're
ready
and uh we'll have a good time you'll be
on the show and we need to [ __ ]
finish uh lone wolf and cup
we were watching that before you left
last time yeah that's right but uh hey
zach showed up hey y'all thank you my
show zach you know i got shirts bro
i got cannon studios i got corralco
studios i got [ __ ] all kinds of [ __ ]
bro 20 super shack i'll send you a show
sure
zack says uh i'd still kill to hang out
with you guys and guest on the show
maybe hey [ __ ] you want to come down and
hang out we can hang out
you know you're not a murderer nothing
like that probably so and we're not
murderers either probably but
but yeah come down and hang out it'll be
a good time
uh yeah so um all right so we were
talking about the nocebo effect
now
they know that it exists obviously
because you know you tell people that a
drug has really negative side effects
and a significant percentage will report
those negative side effects even if the
actual drug doesn't do that
um
but they're still kind of on the fence
they're not real sure
can a person's belief that they're gonna
die
um i mean this does happen but i think a
lot of the evidence is kind of like
anecdotal i don't know how much
double blind stuff because it'll be a
little bit unethical to do these kind of
studies
but you know can it actually kill you
this particular thing
um
so they kind of had i guess they did
some studies back in the 1970s
in the u.s and in australia also
where people were diagnosed with cancer
and
ended up like a
percentage of them actually died
before the cancer
would have killed them so they're kind
of like positing that maybe
these people's
belief that the cancer was killing them
uh made them die earlier than they would
have otherwise had they had perhaps a
more positive attitude not blaming the
victim i'm just saying that
i mean sometimes we've seen it like i
said i think it's a lot of anecdotal
evidence but sometimes people that have
like a more positive attitude oh i'm
going to beat this i'm you know it's not
going to get me or anything like that um
i feel like they tend to live a bit
longer if you get a diagnosis of cancer
and she's like oh well [ __ ] my life is
over then i kind of feel like that
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy i
don't think it has anything to do with
anything paranormal or supernatural or
anything like that but
if you kind of give up you're not really
gonna take care of yourself or you know
your whole attitude is gonna like affect
because stress affects your uh physical
health too like your attitude affects
your physical health too so i think
that's not totally crazy to think that
so
so there have been some studies in that
arena like as far as like people that
were given cancer diagnosis
now another case that probably a lot of
people know about i actually was gonna
do a show about this uh thing but i can
like bring it up now like eventually
i'll do a show about it but uh late 70s
to early 80s there were um all those uh
refugees from uh laos
and i believe this is where um wes
craven got the idea for a nightmare on
elm street actually where the there were
50 of them uh you know or 50 60 of them
and they uh came to the us they were
refugees and they died from what they
called sudden nocturnal death syndrome
um
they basically said they had such bad
dreams that it killed them so like i
said that was where wes craven got the
idea for neighboring homestreet if you
didn't know
um they basically said they did some uh
autopsies on some of the victims they
didn't they didn't have anything wrong
with them they just like would die in
their sleep and they just presumably
were like oh they just had really they
essentially like died of fright
um
but what they found was that some of
them had had some like abnormal heart
rhythms but that was about the only
thing that was wrong with them
and you know they were under a lot of
stress obviously because they were
refugees and uh also a lot of them had
the genuine belief
that
there was an evil spirit like sitting on
their chest at night that's which yeah
which might have contributed to
uh
to them
feeling like they were gonna die in
actual dying because a lot of them
actually did
um
there was also
this other case which uh was brought up
in the new yorker
this happened in 2006 and there was a 26
year old man
who swallowed 29 capsules they were
nothing there was nothing in them they
were just like sugar pills or whatever
he thought that they were he was trying
to kill himself and he thought that they
were antidepressants they weren't there
was nothing in there
um
and so he took them all and even though
there was nothing in them his blood
pressure went like way down and they had
to take him to the hospital now he ended
up he didn't die like after they told
him they're like dude you took all the
you took like 29 capsules and there was
nothing in those they were just like
sugar pills um and then he recovered
after that but
he did take a bunch of pills that had
nothing in them and it had like a
physical effect
so
it's not crazy to think that people's i
mean the mind is it
i kind of feel like the mind and body
you know they're related i don't think
the mind can override all of your body's
uh you know the [ __ ] that your body is
doing but i think that your attitude the
way that you look at things like your
mind has a lot of influence
over your physical
being it's all one thing i don't i think
people tend to think of it even now in
this day and age mind and body as being
two separate things but they're really
not
i mean they're sexy that's what i'm
saying they they really do affect the
other like yeah if your bodily health is
shitty that's obviously going to affect
your mood and things like that but it
goes the other way too like if you are
constantly negative or if you're like oh
my god i'm so sick or i'm this or that
or the other um to an extent that's
going to affect your physical health not
always like like i said sometimes you
don't really have any control over it
but
to a to some degree you do have control
over it okay zach says he'd love to
[ __ ] hang out sometimes look zach
if you want you've been a good friend of
the show for a long [ __ ] time what's
she doing pope yeah what's up she's
scratching on my channel if you want to
come down we got to time it right to
where the weather's cool
yeah don't come down in the summer
seriously you'd hate it right i hate it
weather's cool with the club scene's
good we got an event going on and i'll
[ __ ] uh introduce you toby my [ __ ]
buddy all right and
he's gonna be deep up in that ass
probably you gotta watch these [ __ ]
gay bdsm type [ __ ]
he chased off one boy he was too [ __ ]
weak for him i guess i liked that but he
was yeah he was cool he wore friends he
was a nice too but we met him at the
temple of mercury yeah
[ __ ] toby's looking good he's like
wes from [ __ ] mad max okay you gotta
watch that dude but [ __ ] i'll uh i
can make the introduction i'll get you
as laid while you're up here okay
[ __ ] then we'll see what happens
as for um
so
soap says oh you picked the most
glamorous po
so [ __ ] look soph is [ __ ] very
self-depreciating
self-deprecating self-deficient she she
is soph is a beautiful
young lady
uh uh she uh is young and uh very much
into exploring american culture like
going back to the metal scene and
[ __ ] punk rock and i've showed her
all that because a lot of these young
people they didn't really quite get an
education about what their culture was
but uh so so baby you're always welcome
to come up here okay always [ __ ]
you've been here twice and you've been a
[ __ ] great guest okay
and uh you're a good friend of ours so
just uh come up man it's about time you
broke up with all what's his name you're
single you got your cats up in the
[ __ ] come up and [ __ ] visit come
up and visit we'll have a [ __ ] great
time yeah it'll be fun it'll be fun
yeah
so uh now look just because you're a
listener doesn't mean you're welcome
here
don't be that way we got to know you
everybody in the area is like everybody
in here yeah you all are our buddies
y'all are all okay all our buddies is we
got to know you for if you're here all
the time yeah we talk to you like no
seattle are fine
you know y'all aren't like axe murderers
or nothing that we know of i mean you're
weird we're dealing with but we're also
the public you know we're all so weird
we're dealing with the public but yeah
there might be some like [ __ ]
lurking out there yeah we don't know we
don't know you listen and like not
commenting and they're just like we're
gonna go like stay with those people
soph is famous murder them soap's
basically family she's she knows people
that i grew up with okay she knows
people that she knows people that grant
theirs
grant there's hammer in the comments
section grew up with so that that's the
reason why she came here
camp guy said
what was it granters soph
is friends
with uh jason's little sister
okay
jason's little sister wanted to call it
uh a visit too
jason's little sister really had a crush
on me though i don't know why i said
chicks that [ __ ] might go down sophie
said it's my sister that knows her not
me it's your sister that knows her okay
okay
but you still have a strong kid but you
still know who it is she knows who it is
she knows who it is
jason s says i wonder if soldiers in war
believe they will be killed in battle or
more prone to than the soldier that is
competent to survive
that could be placebo yeah i wonder
explain it i wonder yeah what did they
say
if soldiers were believed they will be
killed like if you go into battle
thinking oh [ __ ] i'm this is i'm not
gonna make it yeah or if you go in there
thinking man i'm gonna get through this
[ __ ] like is that gonna be i'm sure it
does make some difference
well because the thing about it is that
the attitude you have also affects your
behavior
which in some ways might so like i said
i don't think that's supernatural okay
look
i'm from the first three to seventh
infantry [ __ ] i was in a recon
scout unit and the first in the 506 up
in korea so i'm airborne infantry
qualified during wartime
um musashi
writes
a lot of stuff that makes sen
sense to uh fighters
like me
one of the things that he said is he
says
a fighter must have a resolute
acceptance of death in other words you
must believe that you're gonna die
okay and you have to accept the fact
that you're gonna die
but then later on he says and i can't
remember i can't quote directly he says
this the key to success for a [ __ ]
fighter is that
he is dead but he is fighting to regain
life
okay
so in other words you must enter combat
thinking that you're dead and that you
are fighting
to come out of the grave
and i would say that yeah that's true
okay
uh so what did she say
originally [ __ ] i've lost the [ __ ]
um he said yeah
i wonder if soldiers in war believe they
will be killed in battle or more
prominent than the soldier that's
confident to survive the guys that tend
to live
are the ones that aren't stressing over
being killed
the guys that tend to live are the
aggressive ones
who are fighting to survive
very difficult well that's what he's
saying yeah he's just kind of like
you're going to be like [ __ ] it yeah i'm
going okay it's a kamikaze attitude i'm
already dead i'm taking you with me and
they just keep [ __ ] fighting and they
tend to rise to the top because they're
they're not fighting from
a base of being afraid or a base of
being [ __ ] uh defeated already
they're fighting from hatred
uh that's what it is it's hatred hatred
and defiance i'm gonna live and they
tend to rise just despite your despite
your ass yeah yeah you're right right
that's why i'm going to live forever
because i run entirely
right
[Laughter]
some of the best advice i've ever had
from military trainers
and dudes that [ __ ] lift and work out
is they say
exactly opposite of what [ __ ] some
[ __ ] in a university would tell
you
train
from hatred
hatred is actually the key to survival
and victory
it's not anything else
okay
the dark side
is from the star wars well i even like i
don't even know if i don't even know if
i'd call it hatred i would call it more
like i don't want to give like your enem
you don't want to give your enemy the
satisfaction exactly exactly you just
don't want to give us it's not
necessarily hatred i just don't want to
give them the second right and that's
all okay from my point
from my spite but from my feeling it
feels like hatred i don't want to
[ __ ] kill you i mean those are two
different things but yeah i i kind of
feel like spite is a more powerful
emotion than hatred i'm not afraid of
hatred
okay spite is also part of hatred all
right it's just that you will win
okay
you've killed me if only it is just
bad
[Laughter]
that's
far more human and far more practical
and for some reason the body and the
mind responds to that a lot better
lifting weight that you can't lift
hatred helps you
anger and spite okay
which some people would say was like
powers of the dark side well
so be it you're just lifting away well i
mean the thing about it is that as long
as you're not using it to like hurt
other people that don't deserve it then
i mean that's part of the human
experience and they should be utilized
where awareness is exactly
i've never killed anyone that didn't
deserve it
you they [ __ ] deserved it
okay so and yeah there was a lot of
[ __ ] hate in spider
hate and spite spider spider yeah hatred
and spike but they deserved it okay
it's kind of like
a woman giving birth but was it the
reverse of that
you know i mean yeah you gave birth to
him but i took him out
and he deserved it
so it's all just a [ __ ]
it all just depends on how you look at
it and we don't really look at it from
the point of view of say like a
courtroom
or
some pasty white [ __ ] in his
legal [ __ ] books and [ __ ] but no
that's not what it's about this is
animal
this is animal
ability
it has nothing to do with right or wrong
it's just
you did wrong to me
you will pay
which is
bad but so what
so what just ask central and south
america i grew up there [ __ ] it's
about passion
you know camp guy said my old man lived
17 months after the surgeon told us he
had six months to a year my mother
prayed with him every day and stimulated
positive thinking like i said i'm
kind of i mean it doesn't work all the
time like i said eventually your body's
gonna like uh you know [ __ ] you over
because you can't control everything but
i do kind of feel like if you have a
positive attitude
i think that really does help a lot i
mean
if somebody tells you and i mean i don't
know i did the same thing happened
you said uh metastatic gastric stomach
cancer my grandmother died of stomach
cancer also
her thing was that
she was one of those people that i mean
i think she was in pain for a long time
before she told anybody because she's
one of those people and you know i'm
like this too for better for worse where
it's just kind of like when you're in
pain or suffering or something like that
you don't want to trouble anyone else so
you don't tell anybody about it so
that's kind of like what she was doing
so by the time that the pain was so bad
that she couldn't take it anymore and
that we had to take her to the hospital
um the cancer was very very far along
now they went in there and they were
like look we don't really know what
we're gonna define we gotta open you up
and see what's going on
so they go in there and they took out
some of the cancer but they were like
look um we didn't get it all but they're
like uh what's gonna happen is that if
we take it all out that we can see
then you're gonna have like a colostomy
bag or so we're essentially gonna have
to take your whole stomach out because
it's uh it's spread that far
and at that point they're like we can do
that you can have a colossal bag we
could do the chemo and everything like
that and at that point she was just kind
of like no
nope don't want to do it and honestly i
don't really blame her i don't really
blame her um you know they gave her
painkillers she would and we got like a
hospital bed so she could have uh the
bed at home so we could all like stay
with her so she didn't have to be in a
hospital or anything like that i mean
she did get sent to um
hospice in the end but she was only
there for a day or two before she passed
away um so at least she had like
everybody around her but i she was just
one of those people she was just a very
no [ __ ] person and she was just kind
of like look it's not going to help it's
just gonna make my life immeasurably
worse
um i'm just not gonna do it i'm not you
know and she's just like i just wish
they would quit prolonging it it's just
like my time has come and that's just
the end of it and she was like really
you know i mean it was sad because i she
i was very close to her growing up but
it was like really sad when she died but
she was just like not having it not
having it so split she said she had to
do something else she'll be back to
watch the whole show later record it
okay yeah and camp guy said my dad was
76 years old and he stopped chemo very
quickly too many side effects yeah that
was the same kind of thing my
grandmother was just kind of like once
they told her
that hey we're gonna have to take your
whole stomach out or we're gonna have to
chemo we're gonna have to she was just
like absolutely not she's like i'm not
going through all that she's like what
she's like what purpose is it gonna
serve she's like it's just gonna make me
feel like crap and it's just like i
don't know she was 79 by the way
so yeah uh
it's yeah it's just kind of like that's
that's real shitty but yeah
um
camp guy said my mother's best friend
told her doctor she had three sisters
that were all 85 plus years old her
daughter said he didn't need to ask her
any more history i think that lady is
still alive at 90 plus yeah i mean
my i mean on my dad's side of the family
uh you know my grandmother died when she
was 79 my grandfather died significantly
younger but um
how old was he i don't even remember he
was in his 70s too i think but he had
emphysema he had alex he had smoked for
like 40 50 years something like that but
my mom's side of the family seemed
pretty long-lived actually my
grandmother my maternal grandmother is
still alive and she's in her 90s she
actually just had a birthday and she's
in fairly good shape still uh for for a
woman her 90s you know she can still
like get around and stuff i think she's
had a stroke or two but she's still like
uh she's still kicking so you know
my grandfather died but that was several
years ago he had a brain aneurysm he had
died actually quite suddenly
but um camp i said no way i'm gonna let
a doctor do major surgery on me i mean i
can
the thing about it you have to like
weigh
what's your quality of life going to be
like because that's like a pretty big
consideration i mean do you really think
it's like do i really want to live
20 30 years
with you know just like i can't get out
of bed and i you know i have a colostomy
bag or i can't you know what i mean it's
just it depends it depends on what age
you are it depends on how much pain am i
gonna be in is it really worth it you
know what i mean
i don't know
so like i said my grandmother just i
mean she thought it wasn't worth it and
like i said i don't blame her because by
the time they found the cancer and
honestly it was just kind of like
i don't know i'd worry about this a
little bit but not too much because i'm
not that worried about it but
you know she's
i'm a lot like her in the sense that she
just doesn't want to like she doesn't
want to bother anybody she don't want to
bother anybody so she was probably like
in a lot of pain because she had stomach
cancer for a really long time and uh she
didn't tell anybody she didn't tell
anybody that she was in pain for a
really long time so we didn't know until
it was kind of too late to do anything
about it but
she didn't let anybody know because she
didn't want to she want to burden
anybody that was just what she was like
so
you know
um
let's see uh tammy said my grandmother
died just last year at almost 102. her
dad was almost 102 when he died
yeah
zach said uh this makes me think of the
thing about aging gracefully versus
getting a little work done because you
can look good when you do but you can
also turn out like jocelyn wildenstein
i'm not really sure
yeah i mean you honestly i mean you i
don't i'm not averse to like getting a
little work done but don't overdo it man
and honestly like start kind of like
earlier
and do like a little bit at a time you
wait until you're like 80 years old and
then you decide hey i'm going to have my
whole face pulled back and still in the
back of my head that's not going to work
out it's got to be constant and that's
not going to work out for you it's going
to look crazy you need to look into
hormone replacement and um
that'll lead you down the path into
[ __ ] taking slight therapeutic levels
of
anabolic steroids will [ __ ] help you
kind of
age gracefully okay we know we've done
it tammy says cat lady hey i aspire to
be a cat lady yeah i mean you know yeah
yeah yeah that's cool i understand that
yeah cats are way cooler to hang out
with people than people
generally
uh but yeah okay so let's get back to
the premonitions bureau so i can at
least like finish
yeah how much what i'm talking about
let's see how much how much you have
left but not much
depth well that's what i'm saying that's
how is it how long you've been doing the
show three hours okay it's been a good
shot good benefit inside the show let's
go ahead and get a little bit more drink
go ahead and go what have you been doing
the whole time you've been getting up
and leaving went to the restroom
all those times wait did you want to go
to the bathroom with me no what do you
do hold it no i'm just saying that like
you keep getting up and walking around
and i don't know what you just come in
like hold it for me i'll be like go
ahead hold it
nobody wants it nobody wants to hold it
they can't hold it they're like not even
here
all right so let's get back to the like
the premonitions here but i'm almost
done i swear to god
all right so uh during the first year
like i said this is like the pilot
program they want to see how many
premonitions they can
you know collect and how many of them
came true
so they ended up getting 469 predictions
uh
most of these it will surprise no one uh
did not come true uh and some of them
didn't even have anything to do with
disasters like some of them were just
kind of like predicting like which
[ __ ] soccer team was gonna win the
world cup or like [ __ ] like that like
dumb ass [ __ ] that didn't like have any
bearing on any on anything important um
but
the thing about like middleton and
henshir who were kind of like the two
people that came up with
the most predictions that were the most
accurate like i said most of the stuff
that we came up with was didn't come
true or it wasn't it was just kind of
[ __ ] but those two actually did come
up with a few things a handful of
predictions that did seem to come true
or seem to correspond to something that
really happened
now both of them i think separately so
this is something
uh both of them actually predicted a
railway crash
uh they said it's gonna happen on the
main line heading into london i think
that was the only details they had
um
but that did happen november 1st um
i guess well middleton had the vision on
november 1st and she said it was going
to happen at charing cross so that's
like pretty specific
um and four days after that happened a
passenger train going from hastings and
going to that station was derailed on
its way to that station 49 people died
um and henshir also had a similar vision
i think he had like one of his
uh you know premonition headaches or
something like that and he said oh i
think something bad's gonna happen like
to having to do the train crash and that
happened like a day or two before the
train crash so they did seem to like uh
predict that but like i said
a lot of stuff they predicted like
earthquakes and you know [ __ ] like that
like didn't happen but some a handful of
things they predicted did happen so like
i said it's very
it's nothing that could be relied upon
it's just not
like i said there's just nothing you
could like take action on so i i don't
know like i get why they he wanted to do
this like why he had the idea
but
the logistics of
preventing a disaster which i think is
what he wanted i don't know if you would
ever have enough information to be able
to do that
now early 1968 so this is a couple of
years after the abervan accident and the
you know the uh the program is still
kind of going on
now henshaw calls up barker and said
look i still have a really bad feeling
that your life is in danger it's going
to be an accident he said it's going to
be something like that
so just watch your back
now um
he's like you're going to die soon and
it's going to be like in your hometown
like the village where he was living at
the time
now also middleton the other psychic she
also said that early that year 1968 she
also had a vision of him
and she said i saw him and then across
from him was her parents who were
already dead
and she interpreted that as being and
she kept seeing this image like all
throughout this week and she's like and
i interpreted that as like you are going
to join my parents soon it's going to be
like very very soon so you're going to
die soon
and like keep in mind that barker was
not an old man at this time he was only
like in his 40s or maybe early 50s so he
wasn't old
now um
interestingly there was this kind of
okay
what ended up happening kind of on the
sideline like adjacent to that um
the hospital where barker
worked and also david enoch his uh
contemporary
there was a big fire that broke out like
in february of 1968
and it was a locked word and it was
female patients
um
and basically they
really like the nurses and stuff i don't
know if they like didn't know like they
hadn't done fire training or whatever
but a lot of them like took off
uh 24 women ended up dying in the
hospital in the fire
uh four of them actually ended up
surviving because they'd been locked in
like those old school like
like cells that had the big thing like
the big thick doors or whatever
um
so yeah now after that happened
that was one of the things even though
barker had been advocating for you know
more
humane i guess like treatments of uh you
know patients like mental patients and
things like that but this fire uh really
kind of like
put a fire under the ass if you want to
call it that of the british government
there was like a lot of reform of like
the mental health facilities at that
time so that really did kind of help
now what ended up happening after
that uh was that uh barker actually went
to the u.s in may of that year and he
talked about what he his work with
aversion therapy which was still going
on at the time and he also talked about
the premonitions bureau at the american
psychical research society for cycle
research and the guy there said oh [ __ ]
that's a good idea and so he kind of
started up a little bit of a thing in
the u.s as well although i don't think
it went anywhere
but he called they called it the central
premonitions registry so they did one in
the us too but i don't know if it
actually went anywhere because you don't
really hear anything about it
now uh another thing that happened
around this time too
barker gets back home after his u.s trip
and middleton one of his psychics uh she
had kept calling him about
uh robert kennedy
and she kept saying uh she first warned
him on march 11th she's like i think
he's gonna get assassinated she kept
like having visions of it she said
um a couple days after that she wrote to
him again
i keep seeing assassination it has to do
with like robert kennedy um i think
something bad's gonna happen to him she
kept saying
um
and by the time early june came around
she was like freaking out she kept
calling like the premonitions bureau do
so like can't somebody do something
about this i'm sure he's gonna get
assassinated um she called three times
on june 4th which if you know uh that
night he was actually shot and killed uh
shortly after midnight of that day and
uh she had called numerous times and it
was logged that she was sure he was
going to be assassinated so
you know
you know i don't know maybe that was
just a coincidence but she did seem to
like call a bunch of times and they did
log it
um
so yeah so as i said she kind of had um
also a bunch of
premonitions that barker himself was
going to die
now so his experiment which at this
point had been going for about a year
and a half 18 months
so his two most
uh
senior psychics the ones who had had the
most stuff like come true
middleton and henscher
they had both called him separately and
said
we've had predictions we think you're
gonna die
um so whether the two of them calling
him a bunch of times and saying we think
you're gonna die maybe led to him dying
or maybe they foresaw it
nobody really knows
but um spoiler alert
he did die
um august 18 1968 he had a brain
hemorrhage at his house
he was 44. damn he died of a brain
having 44. yeah jesus christ that's
[ __ ] young
isn't that isn't that weird though
because it's like his whole professional
life his whole professional life
he had been interested it's like well
can people that have their deaths
foretold yeah or that like are victims
of voodoo curses or whatever the hell
will that cause a self-fulfilling
prophecy that would cause you to die
and then the fact that he had set up the
premonitions bureau
and a lot of the premonitions they got
like i said didn't come to anything or
it was just kind of like you know just
lucky flukes or whatever but these two
psychics that they had seemed to come up
with a few like a handful of good
predictions that did come true a lot of
[ __ ] that they said did it come true too
like don't forget that but some of the
stuff about like robert kennedy and
about the plane crash and stuff like
that some of the stuff they did seem to
predict both of them apparently
separately
called barker and said we think you're
gonna die we're having like really
really strong like predictions that your
death is imminent and so
was it
them that kept bugging him about it that
actually like caused him to die like the
nocebo effect or was he gonna die anyway
and they were just
foreseeing it that's the interesting
question
but
yeah and apparently middleton one of the
psychics she said um
that the day that he died like before
she found out that he died reportedly
that she woke up in the middle of the
night and like choking and like gasping
for breath and stuff like that and then
she found out later that he had died but
they had both warned him multiple times
and he had written it down he even had
it like in his journals and stuff like
that they both told me that i'm gonna
die and they said it's probably gonna be
an accident or something like that
and that's what happened 44 years old
and he just had a hemorrhage and he
dropped dead in his house
is that crazy that's like so weird
that's so weird but yeah uh but yeah he
died
so uh not too long after he died um
because basically i mean the
premonitions bureau was just him and
like a couple of journalists like
newspaper editors or whatever um so they
didn't really keep it going after
because he was kind of like the brains
and like the passion behind it so after
he died they kind of like they didn't
really do it anymore
so as i mentioned earlier the story of
the british premonitions bureau
uh you know was the subject of a recent
book by sam knight which is called the
premonitions bureau a true true account
of death foretold
and uh interestingly this was actually
there was a 19-way bidding war for the
rights to this book like to adapt it
amazon prime won
so they're gonna do uh either a movie or
a series on it uh which i'm not sure but
actually that sounds really interesting
this is a fascinating story and i'm
actually surprised that i hadn't heard
it before now now
like i said do i think because the dude
his whole
area of study
was people who
had like um you know fortune tellers or
something like that or foretold that
they were gonna die and it made them die
that was like what
fascinated him and the fact that it
seemed like it happened to him
you would think that because he knew so
much about it that he would be immune to
it but maybe not maybe the fact that he
knew about it made him conversely like
worry about it even more and that caused
him to die now rebecca dunn says i
honestly believe my dad wield his death
when my mom died it was crazy
i've heard about that i've heard about
that i got two stories about this
when i was in egypt i used to hang out
with a better one i got photographs of
the [ __ ] me hanging out with the
better ones
and then uh i'd already known him but a
lot about the better ones the better
ones are [ __ ] fantastic arabic people
okay [ __ ] they're smugglers that live
out in the desert
and the ones i used to hang out with
were in the sinai desert
they had camels with them
and evidently
a according to the stories that i heard
or was told
bedouin
knew
when a camel was gonna die
a camel
could give up on life
and lay down and die
and the better one would prevent that
by taking a bunch of [ __ ] hot coals
and throwing them underneath the [ __ ]
camel and get the camel to stand up and
they would [ __ ] smack that camel
around
which would prevent it from dying to
keep it
more
to keep it from going down a damn path
of depression evidently
well it's not crazy to think that
animals might not feel depression of
course they did yeah and they'd
evidently it would work
they'd [ __ ] put coals underneath the
damn camel the camel would stand up and
once the stem camel was up it would try
to get back down they'd smack the camel
in the face
and try to just you can do it can't make
sense into the
ammo
and then the camera would shake it out
and then um
regain life and live
so hell yeah i believe you can will
yourself to [ __ ] die
um
the mind and body are connected yeah you
know
if you uh
get too [ __ ] depressed
and give up on life yeah you can die
i believe so
there was another example that i was
thinking of about this
but i forgot it because i've been
drinking but
but yeah the better ones believed that
they could revive a camel and save it
from death
yeah rebecca said animals will die when
their owners die also yeah i've heard
about that and honestly we've i think we
might have mentioned this on the show
before but not so much nowadays i feel
like but back in the old days
uh when
you know particularly like in the 50s
and 60s and stuff when uh
men of like the you know the world war
ii generation when your kind of whole
identity was based around your job yeah
a lot of times like after men retired
they died they would die like not too
long after because they felt i guess
they felt like they didn't have any
purpose anymore yeah and probably i i
think that this is and this is
completely unscientific this is just
kind of like a cultural thing that i
heard about or noticed
was that because women because a lot of
women were kind of stay-at-home moms
well not all of them it was probably
probably like 50 60 like only just kind
of middle class upper middle class women
working-class women always had to work
but the ones that just kind of like
stayed home and like cooked and did [ __ ]
like that
um i think a lot of them got annoyed
because now
the dudes are home all day just like
laying around in the way yeah and so
like the dudes probably sensed well now
my wife's like pissed off at me all the
time because i'm like in the way while
she's trying to like right have the same
get the household japan done the same
way you know what i mean yeah
they call them useless men
in japan
they were guys that they were retired
from their jobs
and they just had to go back home and
they were useless
they had no skills they couldn't even
cook for themselves
which yeah i kind of feel like
it would drive the women crazy i can see
that so they have to take these guys and
have the center of certain courses to
teach them how to [ __ ] live outside
of a corporate environment like do your
own laundry [ __ ]
funny but understand learn to run a
vacuum cleaner
right learn how to clean up the goddamn
house yeah right learn how to do
something do something outside the
corporate don't just lay there drink a
beer watching football yeah while i'm
vacuuming under your legs
well japan was very corporate
and [ __ ] their whole culture was
based around that especially during the
70s
70s 80s
so by the time those guys became old men
when that culture went away they were
[ __ ]
you know
got to be versatile
all right it's not nothing against the
japanese because musashi would say the
same thing musashi would say you have to
[ __ ] know how to roll with the times
and be versatile don't [ __ ] fix into
one thing you have to [ __ ] see
reality as a whole
okay
and uh learn and [ __ ] once you see
reality as a whole you see the hole in
everything
and um in other words don't zoom in on
little [ __ ] things look at the big
picture
and um
japanese culture didn't didn't
promote that it was about looking at the
little details and finding your little
place in life which like i said you know
two right to a small degree that's okay
but yeah honestly i think the greatest
strength that a person can have is
versatility you got to be versatile um
and adaptability right
uh that's better than anything that's
better than physical strength that's
better than intelligence right that's
better than anything is being adaptable
to whatever situation that you find
yourself in right you got to be
well-rounded
yeah and don't look at one reality there
are many realities you got to like
figure some [ __ ] out however you find so
you got to figure some [ __ ] out right
um yeah and actually i was gonna bring
this up because tammy brought this up uh
there's stories of cats in nursing homes
that will lay on people's beds and then
that would be the next person to die
yeah i've like there's a lot of like i
said it's probably anecdotal but there
are enough of these cases where cats and
sometimes dogs dogs i kind of feel like
it's more like they can smell because i
know that there's some dogs that are um
you know companions for people with like
you know for epilepsy or something like
that and they always kind of like know
when the person is gonna have you know
an episode or an incident or whatever
and they kind of know and they can warn
the person ahead of time every story i
hear about cats is usually cats
know when someone's gonna die like
they'll go like they'll be in a nursing
home for example there's a lot of
nursing homes that have cats because a
lot of you know they're relaxing like to
pet them and you know it lowers people's
blood pressure having them around so a
lot of them have cats but
when
they'll go and sit on someone's bed
at the end of the bed and that means
that person's gonna die yeah and a lot
of people kind of wonder about that well
but you know it's not crazy to think and
i'm sure that humans have the same kind
of like sense it's just that
we have this this whole like frontal
cortex
that's kind of like which is good i'm
not saying we need to get rid of that
but i'm just saying that we have this
whole other layer of
stuff that we have to get through before
we get
to the stuff that like the cats can do
okay this is the last time tonight
i got shirts
cannon studios
any size you want just drop it down
20 super chat
i got
carol carol co another
studio from back in the day
b movies
okay
i got tyrell corporation from blade
runner
okay more human than human
genetic replicants that's the official
logo the tyrell corporation
and then i got
snake pliskin
of course that's bootleg as a
[ __ ] using a ford cobra logo
and then the word pliskin underneath it
so if you guys are interested go ahead
and drop a 20 super chat and then we'll
get your information and i'll send it to
them i got uh
two of them sold maybe three of them
sold already tonight
and uh we'll get those out
was that that ordered that that was uh
what camp guy ordered
danny rowling said where was this
british premies bureau building it they
didn't have a building it was basically
just like three dudes
i mean it was a psychiatrist
and two newspaper guys i don't even
think they had like an office or nothing
like that i think they just kind of like
got together at the coffee shop or in
the hotel room and like talked about
stuff they just kind of like did
everything through the newspaper they
would like i said it was just a pilot
program they wanted to like see if it
would work over a year and then they
were hoping
that it that they could like expand it
out but because
yeah they had some hits but they had a
bunch of misses as well and then the
fact that john barker died weirdly uh
only a couple of years after the program
started um you know he was kind of the
brains behind it so it didn't really
outlast him camp guys said that caraco
had had a lot of big big movies that's
true bro and we're gonna get you a
caraco another week i know you already
bought two shirts this week but [ __ ]
uh another time we'll get you some we'll
get you some carol code later on
danny rowling said dr sleep film had a
death predicting kitty in it yeah yeah
and that's like based on real life
because there's a lot of cats that
actually do that i i liked dr sleep
especially the uh
the long cut of that
the the director's cut
it was a lot better than the uh
than the theatrical cut of dr sleep dr
sleep got didn't get the credit it
should have deserved i thought that was
a great movie
especially the long cut
out of the restroom hold on
jason says maybe fit people that work
hard all their life die younger after
they retire due to lack of routine and
structure they've always had i kind of
feel like that any
i mean it doesn't necessarily even have
to do with fitness i think that if
you've lived
a long time
with a particular structure
uh and you're very into that structure
and it's kind of like defines your life
defines your identity and then suddenly
you retire and you don't have that
anymore i kind of feel like that's
that's why i'm saying i think
adaptability is probably like the the
greatest human strength to have because
if you get so used to something that
when it's taken away you're gonna like
just be in a total quandary and not know
what to do with yourself then that's
probably not good i think it's better to
just kind of like roll with the punches
and just
deal with whatever hands you're given
without and it's you know i know it's
very easy for me to say this because i'm
like like i said i'm like super anxious
and like overthink everything
but
i mean i try not to be that way i'm very
aware that i'm that way so
i try to like
mitigate it
by being does this really need to get
done today is anyone really gonna care
about this as much as i care about this
you know i really try to like
get some distance from it
um but yeah i kind of feel like it's
better and that's why i'm kind of like i
like that i'm not a person that
i don't really like structure or
hierarchy or anything like that like i
like having a structure for myself
because i like to get certain things
done like i'm a very list person i get
up every day i'm like i have to do this
this this and this and it's very
satisfying like when i can mark things
off
but
i only do that but it's just me there's
nobody imposing that on me
when i was in the 101st airborne
division we had a command sergeant major
his name was presley
presley was
in since the 60s
he was in his late 50s or 60s i think
during the time that he left i i gotta
work out the numbers
but he was a
very senior nco
he offered him to go
to the pentagon to become a uh i think
it was a damn
sergeant major of the army and he turned
it down
so he stayed in the 101st
and he was a black
very senior nco who had been in during
the time even when the united states
army was [ __ ] segregated
he was from the triple nickel
which was an all-black airborne unit he
was a [ __ ] great nco everybody
[ __ ] loved him
we lo we watched him go like in around
93 he retired he left
a year later we heard he had died
sad thing
but his whole
identity
was built in the u.s army
and when he left all of his status was
gone all his reason for living was gone
and and somehow he died i wasn't there
he went to wherever he came from and he
died
and it had to be psychological because
he was a strong man when he left
but he just couldn't make that
transition
that's why i think that's why i kind of
think it's probably not good to base
your entire identity yeah
i mean if that's all he was well like i
said i'm not i'm not [ __ ] on people
that have like structured lives and
stuff like that i'm just saying have
something outside of that yeah have
hobbies have like other things you like
to do that you enjoy
because like you're not gonna have
the structure like you're like after you
retire maybe you lose that job or
something like that and it's like so you
can't like base your identity around
that completely his name is command
sergeant major presley
he was a southern guy black guy
and was in the army his entire life
since the 50s at least
i mean holy [ __ ] i was like i said i'm
not i do not like structure i do not
like hierarchy i do not like anything
like that
um
but
honestly i think to myself sometimes i
will never live long enough to do all
the like projects that i want to do
because i'm one of those people that
i'm always open to like new like if i
find out there's some new technology out
there oh this allows you to do this and
that oh i could do that and it's like i
look into it and i'm like oh man i'm i'm
gonna write that down i don't really do
that later so it's like i have like all
these possibilities
and i kind of feel like if you have that
that's probably a good thing to do
because i will never
ever
run out of [ __ ] to do like i have
40 bajillion projects
that if i lived 500 years i would
probably never complete them but i think
that's better than like
not having anything you know i think
that's better so we're done with the
case
yeah okay rebecca says i have complex
adhd i wish less [ __ ] would occupy my
mind yeah i mean i kind of know that
feeling it's kind of like
i tried to tell tom one time i'm like my
brain is like having
a hundred
tabs open
at one time
that you're kind of like constantly
flipping through it's like that but like
all the time
this is why i can't sleep that well
too because it's just i keep like
flipping from tap to tab i'm like oh
this tap oh yeah i gotta flip over to
that it's just it's it's maddening but i
can't do anything about it that's just
kind of like how my brain works so what
are you gonna do what are you gonna do
um
you know
uh jason said i agree life gets in the
way there's always something happening
that can entertain the mind yeah i mean
honestly
there's just so much stuff that i like
and there's just so much stuff that i
wanna do and there's you know so many
movies i want to see so many books i
want to read i was like i would never
get bored if i lived like 100 years or
500 years i would never get bored
because there's so many things i want to
do
but um
you know but i but i get how
some people particularly like like i
said not so much nowadays because i feel
like that's not really the prevailing
attitude but i do kind of feel like
maybe like the world war ii generation
particularly men were just kind of like
their whole identity was based around
like being in the military and then like
having like a company like a corporate
job that you worked there for like 30 40
years then you retired and then after
you retired you're like well [ __ ] now i
don't
presley died now what 12 months
that's crazy yeah but he'd been in the
army for [ __ ] 30 years because he got
used to that
well
he lost all his status he lost all his
purpose
yeah now you're just like a retired just
like a regular dude and he's like [ __ ]
this and he couldn't deal with it he
died
but you know
that was the reality that they
understood
you know
that was the reality that they believed
in that's gone now
your job isn't you you just i really
like that that attitude has gone by the
wayside largely yeah it was a limitation
it was yeah i always kind of saw it as a
limitation even back in the days because
it's just kind of like that's not all
right but people were very very much
into kind of structure and corporate
structure and official [ __ ] and what
your credentials said
none of that was real
i mean it wasn't real in in in the area
in the era of ancient egypt
you could go back to ancient egypt and
had all kinds of [ __ ] of
credentials you'd laugh at that
you're like yeah okay
you give us a [ __ ]
you well that's what i'm saying i'm very
even from a young age i was very aware
yeah that whatever i did didn't really
matter that much to anybody else i was
just like so you know what i'm just
gonna like concentrate on [ __ ] that i
like and [ __ ] that matters to me i don't
give a [ __ ] that like if anybody else
cares about it or not i'm just gonna
like do [ __ ] i like and i think that's a
good way of going about things don't get
too worried about how other people
perceive you or how other people like
what's your status
like what your job is or how other
people perceive your status because
that's very fleeting
and i can guarantee you that 99 of the
people in the world like absolutely do
not care and do not know who you are so
but in a way that sounds shitty but it's
like it's actually really liberating
like no one cares just do it back
in egypt and they had all these [ __ ]
jobs we're [ __ ] high status and [ __ ]
all those jobs are gone yeah nobody has
a [ __ ] about that nobody even knows what
yeah you're a stone worker big [ __ ]
deal you can [ __ ] make a extremely
square stone okay
it's like we have machines to do that
yeah it doesn't matter we're not making
pyramids anymore you know like it didn't
matter yeah i mean well i'm not like
[ __ ] on people back because that was
like for back then that was a good skill
to have yeah but that was i'm just
saying that nowadays we don't need that
everything is [ __ ] changing all the
time that's why is it adaptability yeah
you got to be a dad that is the greatest
human strength adaptability yeah danny
rowling said what is tomorrow's movie
review tomorrow's movie review is
death walks on high heels
i don't know luciano ericoli we haven't
seen that one yet have we i've seen it
you've seen it it's my yellow okay it's
my yellow july okay my flickers for your
thing all right yeah you don't wash
those with me i didn't see that i just
watched this by myself yeah death walks
on high heels all right that's one and
then on saturday
i don't remember who it was that kept
bugging me about doing disco path
but i did do a review of disco path so
that's going up on saturday not exactly
a gel it's more slasher
but it has some jello elements so i said
okay i'll allow it uh but yeah so i did
that too that's also free on to be if
you want to watch it ahead of time
actually uh death walks on high heels
is also on to be as is luciano arcola's
other movie death walks at midnight
which i haven't seen yet okay but um he
did another one called forbidden photos
of a lake of a lady above suspicion
which actually shutter just added so i
might do that at the end of the month i
haven't decided yet but we'll see all
right i'm also gonna do knife advice but
that's next week
um
yeah jason said he felt he lost his
identity your professional life doesn't
define you as a person yeah just define
yourself by who you are what you like
like all the [ __ ] like just be able to
look like what you're wearing okay all
that [ __ ] well well don't be shallow but
i'm just saying that i'm gonna be
slightly shallow but i'm just saying
that
just be a person be a good well-rounded
person don't worry about like you know
if you want your job like if you want
like a cool job and stuff like that and
you're doing something you like then
awesome but don't let your whole life be
defined by yeah people can sell
themselves as anything depending on how
you spin it it's all about
your
narrative although your physicality and
how you look is also a factor
but you can get anything to work
okay depending on how you sell it yeah
because everybody's got their own thing
going on just make your own thing figure
out what it is and make that work for
you yeah don't worry about it don't
worry about it too much and don't worry
about it and here's another thing we
don't live that long no matter what
you're thinking we don't live that long
i mean in the grand scheme yeah we're
gonna die anyway
so
eventually unless they can pop our
brains into avatars right into cyborgs
or some [ __ ] i'm still waiting for that
exactly one of these days yeah
i mean if it doesn't happen that's fine
too but it's like that would be super
cool if they could everybody
i would totally sign up for that
everybody else died we're going to die i
know that's how it is i know i'd say i
know i'm i'm already with that i've made
my piece with that decision but i'm just
saying
if they can upload my brain and put it
in a cyborg then i'll do it yeah but if
they don't that's okay too
either way it's fine all right
so you're done shut it down you're gonna
shut it down shut it down man you got
like super drunk yeah uh you hungry yeah
i'll make you somebody okay good yeah i
haven't eaten for okay hours and hours
and hours
uh
danny rowling said what's dennis btk
think of the british premonition bureau
the british prime minister what
what does that the whole topic of the
show yeah what does dennis think of the
british premonitions bureau
oh well did anybody did anybody in the
british premonitions bureau
have a premonition
of dennis raider
that's the big question
probably not or they would have
mentioned it oh damn you gotta
understand something uh oh here he is
people try to make money and try to make
a job for themselves you know that's all
it is
and
i don't want to talk about it
i mean i'd be drunk he can't do
oh he can't do it
well no one predicted you dennis did
they
you're super special dennis raider wow
look at his little head
we had to glue his little head back on
his headphones his head's on there
no we had glued it off yeah we had a
that's what i just said i said we had to
glue his head back on because it fell
off
we just dropped him on the carpet yeah
his head
it was like really weird
poor dennis nobody feels sorry dennis is
a serial killer we don't we don't feel
therapy we're not worried about that all
right um yeah so this has been a fun
show i feel like yeah probably
i mean at least i got the case covered
without getting too hammered
can't say the same for tom no i'm
[ __ ] but you know
we're gonna go have some food yeah so
you guys have a good uh rest of your
evening and have a good day tomorrow
like i said if you're into giallo movies
um putting up a video tomorrow about
death walks on high heels from 1971 so
if you want to see that it's going up
tomorrow morning at least in this time
zone
so check that out and then we will be
back on friday evening for the side
track show so that should be super fun
and uh also on friday morning we're
putting up a review of francis ford
coppola's one of his first films
dementia13 which we just recorded
earlier so uh that should be fun also so
we'll see you guys again on friday
evening thank you for dropping by thanks
for super chats and we will see you guys
on friday night